Da sind wir wieder.
Guck mal, ob wir jetzt Qualitätsoptionen haben.
Haben wir jetzt Qualitätsoptionen?
Wieder nicht.
Alter, Twitch, ey.
Ihr habt auch keine Qualitätsoptionen, ne?
Ne, ne, ne.
Es buggt wieder.
Twitch, please.
Give quality options.
Ich muss doch Partner werden.
Ich muss. Eigentlich ist das jetzt die optimale
Gelegenheit, mal wieder
jetzt endlich mal meine Partner
Application oder
wie man das nennt, da auszufüllen.
Da krieg ich immer Qualitätsoptionen.
Ihr habt auch keine, ne?
Sackt, Alter.
Easy.
Ja, 1080p oder automatisch.
Soll ich es nochmal ausprobieren?
Soll ich noch einmal neu starten und gucken, ob wir jetzt
Qualitätsoptionen kriegen oder soll ich es so lassen?
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Ich kann es immer.
Ich kann es nochmal neu starten, in der Hoffnung, dass wir jetzt
Qualitätsoptionen kriegen.
Lassen?
Okay.
Wie gesagt, für mich ist das ja kein Problem.
Ich, äh,
hab damit keine Schmerzen.
Stabile 50k. Übrigens, Leute, ich muss euch was zeigen.
Ich muss euch was zeigen.
Nicht mein, nicht mein
Unity Media Flame Video,
sondern ich hab mit dem Unity Media
Support getweetet,
wie heißt denn die Unity Media Hilfe
oder so?
Das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Unity Media Hilfe.
Oder was?
Unity Media hilft?
Ne, aber Moment.
Also, ich zeige euch das mal.
So.
Poggers.
Also, ich hab geschrieben,
vielleicht soll ich das Ganze jetzt erstmal kurz auf Twitter
posten.
Äh,
die Musiklautstärke, okay, so.
Bisschen laut, oder?
Machen wir mal so.
Aber wobei, so in der Mitte, das müsste eigentlich,
eigentlich müsste das ganz gut passen.
So.
Ich hab den gerade jetzt mal auf Twitter gepostet.
Wir müssen jetzt mal aber kurz was
testen.
Wie flüssig das Ganze ist.
Meine, ich muss mal meine
Vorschau, ah doch, meine Vorschau
ist flüssig. Passt.
Ist das Video überhaupt 60fps?
Ah, ne, doch, es ist wirklich 60fps.
Ja, meine Vorschau ist jetzt nicht so wirklich super flüssig, aber es geht.
Ich dachte schon, das ist gar Masters, das Video.
Also, ich wollte euch was zeigen, und zwar, guckt mal hier.
Ähm, ich, ich hab das ja das letzte Mal erklärt, dass ich, oh, ne, jetzt ist der Scheiß hier
noch kaputt.
Oh, Microsoft, please, äh, der Titel passt ja schon wieder.
Und zwar, ich hab ja Upgrade, Upgrade gemacht auf, äh, das Oktober-Update.
Äh, warum?
Warum auch immer das Oktober-Update heißt.
Es ist eigentlich das Dezember-Update, aber Microsoft nennt das Ganze das Oktober-Update,
weil Microsoft der Meinung ist, weil Microsoft wahrscheinlich im Monat nicht richtig zählen
kann und das ursprünglich im Oktober rausbringen wollte.
Äh, bevor ich jetzt, jetzt muss ich erst mal, wo, wo war ich vorher?
Ähm, nicht, dass ich das vergesse davor zu erzählen.
Egal, ähm, ja, also, ich, äh, ich hab geupgradet auf das Oktober-Update und seitdem ist mein
Startmenü, es ist, sind die, sind die Programme weg, ha, und ich hab festgestellt, wenn ich,
ich die Programme neu installiere oder update, machen wir jetzt grad mal, dann sind sie wieder
da.
Logik versteh ich nicht, Microsoft, ich muss mal update, ich muss mal Programme updaten,
was updaten wir denn jetzt, CMD, ja, blablabla, also ich muss Upgrade machen, dass die Programme
wieder im Startmenü da sind, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, das ist schon, äh, richtig,
häh, häh, häng geblieben, das ist echt Windows in 2K, 19 quasi, lull, ja, nachdem
ich jetzt.
Ich muss nämlich in Visual Studio Code eigentlich zeigen, was ich das letzte Mal aufgeschrieben
hab zum Internetanschluss, was, Hack, Alter, Hack, was ist da los, ok, hat trotzdem funktioniert.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die haben den Updateszyklus von Ubuntu abgeschaut, ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
die nennen ihre Updates jetzt ja irgendwie mittlerweile auch nach, äh, Monat und Jahr,
was ich, was ich an sich gut finde, ich find das Ubuntu-Update-System ist eigentlich mit
das Beste.
Ach, Matt, du bist das gewesen, haha.
Ja, ja, ja.
Du hast meine PowerShell-Installation hier quasi gerade abgeschossen.
Verstehe.
So, hat er jetzt, ach, Node, warum haben wir hier überhaupt Node installiert, für was
haben wir nochmal Node installiert?
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr.
Für irgendwas, wenn wir es wohl gebraucht haben.
Wo hab ich denn Node installiert?
Sachen gibt's.
Vielleicht war das Voraussetzung für Postman, das könnte natürlich sein.
Node wahrscheinlich für Vue, ne, wir machen ja noch nicht mal Node mit, also wir machen
ja noch nicht mal Vue mit Webpack und Gedöns.
Wir machen ja Vue ganz normal.
Ja, ja, ja.
Vue ist ganz billig quasi mit Include.
So, wenn das jetzt durch ist, dann kann ich euch zeigen, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen
wollte, weil Windows ja der Meinung ist, mein Startmenü darf nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ich hab's ja letztens auf Twitter auch geschrieben, dass es mit so simplen Sachen überhaupt Probleme
gibt, ne, also das kann ja doch eigentlich keiner mehr erzählen, dass nach einem Windows-Update
das Startmenü nicht mehr geht.
Das ist doch eigentlich, dass so, so simple, essentielle Dinge schiefgehen können, das
verstehe ich einfach nicht.
So, ist mein Update jetzt irgendwann mal fertig?
Können wir, ah, wir können Visual Studio Code schon aufmachen.
Und zwar, wir hatten das letzte Mal uns doch hier gespeichert, was ich mit meinem Internetanschluss
machen könnte.
Und zwar, ich hatte ja zur Auswahl nochmal so ein Recap für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt
haben.
Aktuell ist es so, also aktueller Stand ist, ich habe einen Internetanschluss von der Telekom,
einen VDSL 100 mit 40 ab, 100 runter und Telefon.
Und ich habe einen Unity Media Internetanschluss.
Internetanschluss mit 100 down, 6 ab, Fernsehgedöns, ja, genau, also so sieht das aktuell aus
bei mir.
Und das ist, geh weg, und das ist einfach zu teuer, deswegen will ich einen von beiden
wegschmeißen.
Die Kombination an sich habe ich nur aus dem einzigen Grund, weil ich mehr Upload wollte
und zum damaligen Zeitpunkt Unity Media leider nicht mehr Upload hatte.
Und deswegen habe ich gesagt.
Okay, ich mache bei der Telekom VDSL anstatt 16K, was ich am Anfang hatte.
So, das war der Hintergedanke.
Und jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit bei der Telekom, dass ich 250, die haben ausgebaut
bei uns, also die haben jetzt quasi ihr VDSL Vectoring Gedöns, haben sie noch dabei gemacht.
Okay.
Und jetzt kann ich bei der Telekom kriegen 250 down, 40 ab.
Habe ich gesagt, ja, an sich hätte ich aber am liebsten, am liebsten hätte ich die Telekom
weg.
Weil ich streame jetzt ja immer über die Telekom.
Und wir haben, wie oft ist der Stream schon abgebrochen?
Weil die Telekom ist ja immer wieder weg.
Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ich habe die Telekom jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich habe die Telekom mal wieder.
Der Meinung war, DSL Modem verliert Sync oder Telekom hat scheiß Verbindungen zu vielen
CDNer, zu vielen Content-Geschichten, zu YouTube hat ja Telekom schon traditionell eine scheiß
Verbindung.
Und Telekom ist bei mir nicht sonderlich stabil und auch die Verbindung hin ist bei vielen
Sachen scheiße.
Deswegen würde ich am liebsten die Telekom loswerden.
Das war Super Vectoring wahrscheinlich, ja, also das, wo man 250 down kriegen kann.
Okay.
Und deswegen wollte ich eigentlich, und das haben wir ja hier das letzte Mal aufgeschrieben,
deswegen wollte ich eigentlich komplett zu Unity Media wechseln, weil Unity Media hat
jetzt einen neuen Tarif, 400 MBit down, 40 ab mit Power Upload und es ist sogar noch
ein paar Euro billiger.
Wohlgemerkt, da kommt noch der Kabelanschluss für Fernseher dabei, aber den, ja, den bräuchte
ich ja so oder so.
Moin, Andel.
Den bräuchte ich ja so und so.
Und das große Problem.
Was ist das?
Und das große Problem bei Unity Media war das hier.
Ich habe ja mit denen schon lange rumgezaggert bei meinem Unity Media Anschluss, dass ich
wieder einen ordentlichen, also ich hatte, ich hatte Probleme, ich habe es euch ja das
letzte Mal gezeigt, ich hatte damals Probleme mit YouTube Upload, das hat irgendwie 3000
Stunden gedauert, jetzt ohne Scheiße, statt wirklich im Upload Balken, vielleicht erinnert
sich der eine oder andere noch drinnen.
Warum nicht Vodafone?
Vodafone hat bei mir nichts eigenes, die haben bloß Resale gedönst.
Ja, jetzt habe ich zu viel Chat geguckt.
Wo bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Also und ich habe ja mit Unity Media lange hin und her gezaggert, damals auch auf Twitter,
weil wie gesagt, 3000 Minuten YouTube Uploads, das, dafür habe ich es mir damals nicht geholt,
das ist halt total affig.
Und ja, ja, Nilsson, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich will, ich will den Kabelanschluss hier
haben für Fernsehzeug, aber ich will kein Triple Play mehr, weil die Zusatz Fernsehdinger
brauche ich nicht.
Ja, und warte mal, ich bin, ich habe voll aus dem Takt gekommen.
Zumindest.
Ja, genau.
Und dann habe ich dann irgendwann ordentlich IPv4 wiedergekriegt bei Unity Media und gut
war.
Und das Problem ist jetzt bei der ganzen Geschichte, normalerweise hört man ja immer
schlechte, schlechte News, wenn man jetzt beispielsweise seinen Vertrag umstellen und
upgradet, dass man dann auf einmal wieder Dual Stack Lite kriegt, also diesen, diesen
Kack hier.
Und den wollte ich nicht.
Und ich habe mir ja auch überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach Unity Media Business holen
soll.
Mal davon abgesehen, dass es auch nicht so viel billiger ist als jetzt 2,5 Millionen.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist auch nicht so, dass es nicht so viel billiger ist als jetzt 2 Anschlüsse.
Aber die haben kein Power Upload.
Da gibt es nur maximal 20 oder 25 MBit Upload, was irgendwie auch kacke ist, wenn die normale
Variante für den 0815 Benutzer schon 40 hat.
Warum Business Leute nur 25 kriegen, man weiß es nicht.
So.
Und nun habe ich gedacht, fragst du doch mal die Unity Media Support auf Twitter und ich
habe jetzt bla bla bla, zwei Leitungen, Unity Media, Telekom hauptsächlich, Unity Media
jetzt aktuell nur noch als Backup.
Eine soll weg.
Mein Anschluss ist nicht mehr DSLite, Problem mit IPv4.
Ja und VPN.
Das ist nicht nur YouTube, damals VPN war ein Riesenproblem.
VPN war echt ein Riesenproblem.
Ich hatte Probleme mich einmal von der Arbeit zu verbinden, also von dort, sei es jetzt
über das Handy, VPN oder sowas, heim, wenn ich nachgucken wollte, was die Heimautomatisierung
macht oder irgendwas.
Ging nicht richtig.
Also besser gesagt ging gar nicht, weil wir da nur IPv4 haben.
Du kannst vergessen, du kommst halt nicht ordentlich von IPv4 auf IPv6 und umgedreht ging
es auch nicht.
Ich konnte, ich konnte quasi kaum mit diesem Getunnel von Unity Media, konnte ich quasi
nicht per VPN von mir daheim auf die Arbeit.
Das ist natürlich noch eine beschissenere Kombination, ja, weil das ist ja, das ist
ja irgendwo notwendig gewesen und da haben die das umgestellt.
So und jetzt habe ich gefragt, bleibt, kann ich IPv4 behalten, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
hier auf Fly 400 upgrade.
Und.
Da hat der Unity Media Typ gesagt, der Patrick hat das mal ein bisschen rum geflamed.
Ähm.
Was sonst?
So.
Und da sagt er, hey, du behältst IPv4 auch bei der Umstellung deines Vertrages.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, jawoll, sehr nice, sehr nice, dachte ich mir, das ist, das ist
schön.
Nilson, ich hätte auch am liebsten einen richtigen Dual Stack anstatt IPv4, so einen ordentlichen
Dual Stack halt.
Und da habe ich gesagt, okay.
Geht das auch, dass ich umsteige von 100 MB?
Triple Play, weil da ist so Zusatz Fernsehgeschiss drin, was kein Mensch braucht.
Wollen wir wenden, der Support hat von IPv4?
Keine Ahnung.
Der Support ist nicht schlecht.
Also die ganzen Social Media Support Typen, sowohl von der Telekom als auch von der Bahn
als auch von Unity Media und so was.
Das ist eigentlich der beste Support, wo man sich bei den ganzen Läden hinwenden kann.
Jetzt ohne Scheiß, Leute, wenn ihr, wenn ihr wirklich mal mit Leuten reden wollt, ja,
wo dann, wo dann auch welche da sitzen, die irgendwie bisschen Ahnung haben, dann wendet
euch an den Social Media Support von den ganzen Leuten.
Das ist, das ist wirklich die beste Variante.
So, und da habe ich ihn gefragt, geht das denn jetzt, dass ich das, das alte 100 MB Triple
Play plus Kabelanschluss umstelle auf einen neuen 400 MB Two Play mit Power Upload Kabelanschluss,
weil ich die Zusatz TV Angebote nicht haben will?
Und dann sagt er, das können wir machen.
Bitte Kundentaten per TM.
Habe ich noch nicht, weil ich muss erst mal noch, na, big brain, erst mal noch die Karte
machen.
Erst mal gucken, wie ich das genau mache vorher, weil ich muss Telekom noch kündigen
und da muss ich ja irgendwie noch die Telefonnummer von der Telekom, bevor ich kündige, portieren.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, nachdem es immer so ein Riesenakt ist mit Telefonnummern, weil
wir haben halt noch eine relativ gute Orts, Ortstelefonnummer, auch wenn ich persönlich
damit nicht telefoniere, meine Mutter telefoniert hier, alt old school, ja, mit, mit Telefon
und wir haben halt noch eine Ortsvorwahl und es kennen auch alle nur unsere Ortstelefonnummer.
Das heißt, wir müssen irgendwie diese komische Telefonnummer behalten.
Ja.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, bevor ich die Telefonnummer jetzt zu Unity Media portiere
und es wieder die Leute vor unlösbare Aufgaben stellt, portiere ich die Telefonnummer von
der Telekom einfach zu einem VoIP-Anbieter für 2,50 im Monat und mache darüber mein
Telefonzeug und kündige die Telekom komplett.
Alles weg.
Komplett weg, Telekom.
Brauche ich nicht mehr.
Und das war dann die optimale Kombination.
Dann hätte ich nämlich das hier, so ungefähr für, äh, sogar, sogar nochmal, sogar nochmal
für, äh, sogar nochmal 10 Euro billiger.
Das ist der Witz.
Habe ich nämlich bei Unity Media im Kundencenter gelesen.
Die wollen diese alten Verträge nicht mehr haben.
Die wollen diese alten 100 MB Tripleplay-Dinger nicht mehr haben.
Die bieten einem an, jetzt quasi für 10 Euro weniger im Monat, als es normalerweise kostet,
ähm, umzusteigen.
Das heißt, das hier würde sogar nur 43 Euro kosten.
Ich vermute mal nur die ersten 12 Monate oder so, ja, irgendwie sowas.
Ähm, müssen wir mal genauer gucken.
Und da drauf kommt natürlich nochmals 20 Euro für den Kabelanschluss und da bin ich
bei 63 Euro und das ist ungefähr, ungefähr, so über den Daumen gepeilt, die Hälfte von
dem, was ich jetzt im Monat bezahle und, ähm, ich habe einen schnelleren Internetanschluss
und alles.
Und in einem Jahr oder so, wenn ich, wenn ich dann mir was anderes überlegt habe, kann
man vielleicht den Kabelanschluss auch abbestellen, weil der ist dafür nicht erforderlich.
Das ist nämlich auch gut im Vergleich zu Tripleplay.
Nee, danach ist Clocks, danach ist glaube ich, danach sind glaube ich die 53.
Also im ersten Jahr kostet glaube ich nur 39, stimmt.
Danach wieder 53.
So, also dann bezahle ich im Endeffekt halt hier 73 im Monat für Internet, Telefon, nein,
ja gut, nee, 45, weil es kommt auch ein 2 Euro VoIP-Anbieter drauf.
Dann bezahle ich quasi 75 Euro im Monat für Internet, Telefon, Fernsehen.
Das ist okay.
Ähm, ja.
Ja, und ich habe mir auch mal, ich habe ein bisschen mit Dings hier rumgebastelt.
Mit denen hier.
Das ist ja auch so ein, so ein Fernseh-, Fernseh-, ähm, wie nennt man das?
What?
Nee, das ist kein Video on Demand, wie, wie heißt denn das?
Ja, Fernseh-, TV-Streaming-Dienst, ähm, der mittlerweile in Deutschland, habe ich gesehen,
auch die privaten, bis auf RTL, in HD-Auflösung hat.
Und das Geile ist, was ich gefunden habe, das ist nämlich auch nochmal Option, ne Option,
es gibt nen, ja, ich promise es, ich habe noch die richtigen IPv4.
So, und ich habe nämlich ein Skript gefunden, auf, äh, Github, für, für Satu, Satu, wie
auch immer man die genau ausspricht, wo man quasi mit nem Satu Premium-Abo die, ähm,
ganzen Geschichte in TV-Headend reinkriegt.
Und das Ding verwende ich ja aktuell eh schon als TV-Server halt mit, mit, mit, ähm, ähm,
Unity Media mit, mit Kabel, mit DVB-C-Karte drin.
Und das wäre natürlich nochmal cooler, weil, da könnte man sich auf lange Sicht die 20
Euro für den Kabelanschluss sparen und bräuchten nur 10 Euro für das, äh, Premium-Abo.
Also ihr seht ja, ich habe, ich habe ein bisschen gerechnet.
Und da sind die privaten in HD mit drinne, bis auf RTL, was es bei anderen nicht drinne
gibt.
Bei dir ist RTL auch in HD drinne?
Ja.
Nee, das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Achso, ja, aber du kommst nicht aus Deutschland, oder?
Nee, guck, weil in Premium haben die das nicht.
Warte mal.
Oder doch?
Ach, dann ist das mittlerweile drinne.
Okay.
Ja, auch gut.
Habe ich auch keine Schmerzen mit.
Wie wäre es mit einer Sat-Schüssel?
Ja, das ist die nächste Option.
Das könnte man auch machen.
Warum will man eigentlich RTL schauen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin in dem Fall nur aus, ausführender.
Ich gucke ja gar keinen Fernsehen.
Ja, aber so machen wir das.
So in der Richtung werden wir das machen.
Ähm, na, wir ist jetzt übersagt, weil ihr in der Chat macht ja nicht mit bei meiner Internetauswahl.
Aber darauf wird es wahrscheinlich rauslaufen.
Und wenn ich 400, 400 MBit down habe, ja, da ist auch mal irgendwie 2, 5, 6 MBit HD Fernsehstreams
ohne Probleme drinne.
Das juckt es ja manchmal 400 MBit down mal absolut gar nicht.
Gut.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Eigentlichen.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Eigentlichen, was ich heute machen will.
Und zwar, ähm, ich zeige es euch mal.
Für die Leute, die den Anfang nicht mitgekriegt haben davon.
Wo ist es denn hier?
Proggas ist es.
Hast du die Sync-Abrüche mal prüfen lassen?
Ja, ich habe mal mit dem, sie haben gemessen und, äh, ihr kennt, das ist so die Standardantwort immer so nach dem Motto.
Ähm, ja, hier irgendwie Sync, Sync verliert immer.
Habe ich, findet man auch irgendwie auf Twitter.
Wir haben ihre Leitung gemessen und jetzt ist alles wieder gut.
Es ist aber nicht.
Es war mal eine Zeit lang noch schlimmer.
Und ich habe in der Fritzbox den Kram schon runtergestellt auf quasi stabile Verbindung über Qualität oder sowas, was auch diese Option überhaupt macht.
So, ähm, also für alle, die es noch nicht kennen.
Ich zeige das mal kurz.
Und zwar, ähm, wir haben in den letzten 2 Streams für Hardware-Rad ein Tool gebastelt, mit dem sie ihre Windows-Rechner aktivieren können.
Ich zeige das mal.
Auf Windows-Keys liegt!
Gebated.
Massive gebated.
Hat mir eh keiner geklaut.
Ähm, warum ist denn das andere Tool jetzt auch abgekackt?
Habe ich das jetzt?
Moment.
Moment, ich glaube, ich habe das andere auch irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Ne, geht doch.
Was auch immer.
Ähm, ja.
Ich glaube, ich habe das andere auch irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Ne, geht doch.
Was auch immer.
Ähm, ja.
Also, ich habe hier so ein Tool gebastelt, wo sie ihre Keys verwalten können.
Übrigens, das sind, also für alle, die jetzt wirklich irgendwie gedacht haben, das sind, äh, das sind, sehen zwar aus Windows-Keys, das sind die Keys, die Microsoft offiziell bei ihrer Seite stehen hat, wenn es um KMS-Test-Keys geht.
Das ist nichts Tolles drin.
Plus, ein paar sind auch ungültig, weil ich ja einen da dazwischen geschrieben habe.
So, und wer das Tool das letzte Mal gesehen hat, weiß, das ist, ähm, war ein bisschen simpler.
Und ich habe es jetzt noch ein bisschen erweitert.
Man kann jetzt quasi einen Kommentar einfügen.
Wenn man Keys hinzufügt.
Ähm, ein bisschen größer.
Wenn man, man kann den Kram bearbeiten.
Da geht so ein, das ist richtig fancy, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Bam!
Ha? Ist das nicht geil?
Guck hier.
Bam!
Geht das Fenster auf.
Ja, ja. Das ist richtig, ja.
PogChamp.
Easy.
ProGear.
So, ähm.
Ja, und da kann man jetzt hier hinzufügen quasi einen Kommentar.
Kann man hier sowas, also, das sollte nicht für Kappa HD Omega 0 0 frische Keys verwenden sein, sondern
da kann man sowas reinschreiben wie
Keylieferung vom 01.12.2018
zum Beispiel. Ja, so ein bisschen seriöse Geschichte.
Und wenn du dann da drauf klickst,
kriegst du halt alle Keys, die du
Guckt euch mal an, wie schön sticky das ist.
Seht ihr das hier oben?
Wenn man scrollt, die Tabelle
bleibt oben.
Ist nice, oder?
Findet ihr das nicht auch nice?
Guckt man scrollt und zack, die Tabelle bleibt oben.
Krasser Shit.
Richtig, richtig
klebrig sind wir auch, ja.
Ja, und wenn man dann hier, kann man die unterschiedlichen
Keylieferungen durchklicken
und die gehen immer auf.
Die sehen jetzt bloß gleich aus, die sind nicht gleich.
Ich hab halt immer die gleichen Keys wieder kopiert.
Also, wieder die gleichen Keys
mit leichten Änderungen drinnen.
Mit was wurde das Framework designt?
Also, was? Nein.
Mit was wurde das Interface designt?
Also, da ist
Vue.js drunter.
Wobei die Optik ist mit keinem
das ist einfach
so wie es meinem Hirn entsprungen ist.
Dementsprechend sieht das TSS
auch nicht allzu schick aus.
Ja, und ich zeige euch nochmal was.
Ich zeige euch nochmal was.
Was auch richtig nice ist.
So.
Wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Gegen eine Prise Bootstrap.
Ja, weil ich benutze das ja hauptsächlich
dazu, dass ich erstens was
programmiertechnisch zu streamen habe
und zweitens, dass ich selbst ein bisschen was lerne.
Und wenn ich ein fertiges Bootstrap
machen würde, dann würde ich da nichts bei lernen.
Ja.
Ach ja, was richtig nice ist, was ich euch noch zeigen wollte.
Und zwar, also mal angenommen
man sagt jetzt hier
neue Keylieferungen hinzufügen.
Dann können wir jetzt sagen, was weiß ich.
Neue Keys
vierter, zwölfter
neunzehn Uhr
So, das erste, wenn da nichts drinnen steht
und ich sage jetzt absenden
dann macht er BÄM. Kommentar darf nicht leer sein.
Fehlermeldung. Server-Side.
Ja. BÄM.
Kommentar darf nicht leer sein, sagt er jetzt.
So, und dann wollen wir jetzt einen Kommentar reinschreiben
und versuchen die Keys zu pasten
und dann sagt er, Keys können nicht leer sein.
Und noch viel geiler,
wenn ich da jetzt reinschreibe
lulalderlan oder sowas, dann sagt er
Key not valid.
Ha? Ha?
Das ist schon sehr nice, oder?
Muss man mal sagen.
Das ist schon sehr nice.
Und wenn man da jetzt was ordentliches reinschreibt
sowas wie hier, also ich meine
ob das wirklich ein gültiger Windows-Key ist
kann er ja nicht ausprobieren, da muss er halt auf den Regex matchen.
Wenn wir jetzt sowas hier machen
das ist ein gültiger
Windows-Key, zumindest vom Format.
Zack.
BÄM. Da ist er. Neue Keys.
Es ist sortiert nach dem
neuesten, also es ist
gruppiert nach
den, nach den, ja halt
nach der
Lieferung, nach dem Kommentar
und insgesamt
nach Datum. Das heißt, die Neuesten
sind immer zuerst. Und ich habe
Coggers mittlerweile auch geändert. Coggers ist
der Kommandozeilen-Client, den man
auf die Rechner zieht, um es dann letztendlich
ein Dubletten-Filter
wäre auch nice. Ich
habe, glaube ich, sogar
einen. Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Ich glaube, ich habe einen Filter, dass doppelte
Keys nicht gehen. Aber ich glaube, der wirft
noch keine Fehlermeldung. Warte mal, wir probieren das jetzt
mal einzufügen.
Ja, macht er nicht, aber er wirft
keine Fehlermeldung. Das können wir noch machen,
wenn ein doppelter Key drin ist.
Guck, er macht es nicht, sonst würde jetzt hier ein neuer Key kommen.
Also, ich filtere doppelte Keys
schon raus, aber
der wirft
noch keine Fehlermeldung.
Ja, aber findet ihr es nicht nice?
Ihr guckt mal hier, wie das wackelt.
Und dann, es faded aus nach
vier Sekunden. Seht ihr?
Wackelt, wackelt. Hallo?
Kommentar darf nicht leer sein. Und letztlich
gleich, krass, oder?
Ja, hier oben fügt man neue
Keys hinzu und
hier editiert man halt die alten. Ach ja, und übrigens,
das Löschen funktioniert jetzt auch.
Wenn ich jetzt sagen will, ich will neue Keys löschen,
sag ich einfach, zack. Und dann kommt noch mal eine Abfrage.
Bla, bla, bla, einfach löschen, okay.
Bla, weg, weg ist er.
Sehr nice, ne?
Sehr nice.
Ah, da hat er auch noch, ja,
das stimmt noch. Aber wer auch immer das geschrieben hat,
hat recht. Wir sollten noch einen Filter
einbauen, dass doppelte Keys
nicht, äh, nicht eingelegt
werden können, beziehungsweise auch
übergreifend und vor allem, dass eine ordentliche Fehlermeldung
kommt. Den
Modal könnte man auch schöner machen. Meinst du
den hier oder meinst du
den hier? Meinst du das
Popup? Den Alert.
Das ist so ganz normale Browser
Alert Box. Kann man die stylen?
Ne, die kann man nicht stylen, oder?
Den Alert kann man nicht stylen.
Das ist halt von
halt der Chrome Alert ist das.
So, ähm,
ja, das ist das Tool. Zwar man sieht da so
Dinger wie, ähm,
hier jetzt bei mir nicht so viel drinne, weil da so
die Testrechner sind. Man sieht hier beispielsweise drinne,
also in der Übersicht sieht man nur die Keys,
die noch quasi unbenutzt sind.
Hier hat man unter Logs hat man dann
eine History stehen, welchen, welchen
Rechner man aktiviert hat mit, ähm,
also welchen
Rechner mit welcher Mac man wann
aktiviert hat. Da steht,
ich hab gestern die, die, die, die, ähm,
Windows Key Datenbank
von, von den Jungs gesehen
und da ist natürlich mehr, mehr unter
Logs aktivierte Rechner drinne, wie, wie Key.
Ja, ähm,
ja und bei Stats sieht man ein bisschen Zeug wie
aktivierte Rechner heute und so. Das ist noch relativ
rudimentär, da ist jetzt noch nichts großartig drinne.
Ist das auch SQL Injection
sicher? Ich denk mal
allzu viel injecten kannst du da nicht.
So, äh, vorausgesetzt, äh,
EF Core
spackt nicht rum.
Dann mach ich mir da relativ wenig Gedanken.
Da sind, sind keine, keine selbst
zusammengebauten SQL Dinger drinne
im, im laufenden Betrieb.
So.
Ja, okay und jetzt machen wir weiter. Und zwar
eine Sache, die wir noch einbauen müssen
ist, ähm, es ist mir nämlich aufgefallen,
dass es noch sehr praktisch wäre,
wenn dieses Tool, also
das funktioniert ja folgendermaßen,
es gibt ja noch nen Kommandozeilen-Client
dafür, nämlich
Proggers ist hier der Server mit den, mit den
Keys drinne und
Coggers, beste
Programmler aller Zeiten, ey.
So und, und, und
Coggers,
ähm,
macht so Dinger wie,
oh ja, hab ich schon angefangen, versucht ein bisschen Zeug
mit Formatieren zu machen, nee, nee, nee, das kommt weg.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, geh weg.
Der Nightbot geht ab.
So, ähm,
und das hier ist das, äh, Client-Programm,
das kommt quasi auf die Systeme drauf,
die installiert werden und, ähm,
der aktiviert Windows.
Der aktiviert übrigens auch noch nen Test-Key, also
müssen wir gar nicht probieren. Der aktiviert Windows.
Im Hintergrund.
Also, der macht ein paar Fenster auf und aktiviert Windows
dann. Und das funktioniert
relativ zuverlässig, da gibt's
eigentlich keine Probleme. Und jetzt, ähm,
haben sie sich
gedacht, es wäre noch ganz nice,
wenn das Programm auch Festplatten formatieren könnte.
Ja, und,
ähm,
der Floji baited.
Der Floji
baited, das ist nen,
das ist nen Windows,
äh, KMS-Key,
das ist nen Windows-KMS-Key,
der funktioniert nicht.
Also,
lasst euch nicht gebeten.
Okay, ähm, so, und jetzt
versuchen wir mal einzubauen,
dass man damit auch
Festplatten. Wie kann man
Seite-for-SQL-Injection schützen?
Das einfachste ist, keine
eigenen SQL-Querys basteln.
Und wenn man eigene
SQL-Querys bastelt,
dann, oh, wie hieß der Kram?
Ich hab schon das Problem, dass mir den Namen, den
haben von manchen dinge nicht einfach obwohl man so eigentlich normalerweise verwendet parameters
also sprich beispiel ja wenn du keine sql prepared state prepared statements heißt glaube ich ja ich
glaube so hieß der kram ja also du hast du hast die möglichkeit so die billig variante ist so
was hier sql dann sagst du sowas wie hier select kogas from poggers oder was hier so was ich select
top also das wäre oder sagen wir wea wea blub gleich eins oder wie geht das in sql einfach nur so gell
das wäre das war so die billig variante von also sagen wir mal so dass das hier ist user input
user input
ist in dem fall eins und die billig variante sql wo man auf jeden fall probleme kriegt wer
das hier da das ist klar event effekt ich kriegte in den input vom user ist egal wie ich den krieg
ob ich den jetzt über das terminal krieg als post irgendwie als request vom web oder das ist egal
wenn ich sowas hier basteln dann sind probleme vor programmiert also das wird auf gar keinen
fall machen weil ich so was hier basteln dann sind probleme vorprogrammiert also das wird auf gar keinen fall machen weil
also das wird auf gar keinen fall machen weil
du kannst jetzt hier anstatt eins kannst du dir auch so was hier über das übergehen so und wenn
du wenn du jetzt das hier übergibt ist und das einfach hinten dran hängst dann wird zuerst
ausgeführt sehr læ styles diepreis nicht vor dass linken überbehalten sie legt
sternchen rutgers vom mología blubb gleich user input eins ist gültiges statement ein
Und danach führt er allerdings noch Drop Table Bashing alle aus.
Das ist schlecht.
Das ist ganz schlecht.
So macht man das nicht.
So, die nächste Variante ist, man verwendet so ein bisschen lighteres SQL Mapper, SQL Framework.
Da kann man dann sowas hier in der Richtung machen.
Ich mache das jetzt nur mal sinnbildlich, weil ich nicht weiß, wie ich überhaupt mit EF Core das machen würde.
Also, mal angenommen, du hast, achso, ja, früher hat man das so gemacht, dann hatte man so eine Funktion, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie, irgendwie, ich kann das gar nicht schreiben, User Input.
Und dann hast du das hier irgendwie reingepiped und dann hat er geguckt, ob da nicht verbotene Zeichen drin sind und sowas.
Viel zu kompliziert.
Die meisten SQL Frameworks Mapper und sonst was bieten sowas hier an, dass du sagen kannst, hier sowas, was weiß ich, SQL.
Und dann sagst du, so ungefähr, ja, es ist immer von Framework zu Framework unterschiedlich, User Input.
Dann würdest du das nämlich so machen und das setzt quasi den ersten Parameter an dieser Stelle ein, sorgt allerdings dafür, dass jegliche, wenn es gescheit gemacht ist, jegliche User Inputs und sowas, dass das alles gereinigt wird und kein Scheiß ausgeführt wird.
So.
Und noch, noch schöner ist es eigentlich, wenn du einen kompletten Datenbank Mapper verwendest, da machst du nämlich einfach nur noch sowas hier.
Äh, wo sind, wo sind meine Controller?
Da.
Da machst du nämlich nur noch sowas hier.
Da hast du einen Datenbank Kontext, wo du sagst, ähm, keine Ahnung, ich will, äh, in die Datenbanken will ich eine Collection von Windows Lizenzen drinne haben und dann kannst du noch ein paar Zeug, aber im Prinzip egal.
Du schreibst kein SQL Mapper von.
Und das generiert quasi, in dem Fall ist es EF Core, Entity Framework Core, alles für dich und dann sagst du in deinem Controller am Ende, bloß noch sowas hier, ähm, ja, sowas hier wie, äh, Context, Get Unused License, Order By, bla bla bla.
Das ist im Prinzip auch irgendwo SQL, du kannst ja auch sagen sowas wie Where, irgendwas, bloß, dass du halt überhaupt keinen SQL Text mehr selbst zusammenbaust, sondern, ähm, da kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr.
Sondern, ähm, da kann ich überhaupt nichts mehr passieren.
Schon RIP von Tumpler gehört.
Ne, hab ich nicht, aber ist Tumpler nicht das, was Yahoo irgendwann mal übernommen hat?
Ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo Yahoo was übernimmt, ist einem eigentlich klar, ähm, dass es nix wird.
Okay, so.
Jetzt gehen wir zum, kommen wir mal zum, zum eigentlich, was wir heute machen.
Jetzt hab ich ja hier ein bisschen drumrum geschwätzt, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Heute formatieren wir Festplatten mit C Sharp.
Und ich hab mir im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen angeguckt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Und wir müssen das natürlich in der VM machen.
Ach ja, noch eine andere Sache.
Habt ihr, habt ihr gehört, dass, ähm, ach, VM war starten.
Habt ihr gehört, dass Microsoft angeblich, weil es gerade einer im Chat schreibt, dass Microsoft angeblich an einem neuen Edge-Browser arbeitet.
Der nicht mehr Edge ist, sondern Chrome.
Edge ist anscheinend Geschichte.
Wenn man den Gerüchten glaubt, ja.
So, also wir müssen dann unsere Windows-VM jetzt erst mal, ach ja, übrigens, ich, das mit dem Festplatten-Formatieren machen wir selbstverständlich in der VM, weil ich keinen Bock hab, meine, meinen Rechner irgendwie zu formatieren oder zu löschen oder sowas.
So, wir hängen mal testweise eine Platte dran.
Warum hab ich die eigentlich gelöscht?
Ich hatte doch schon eine dran.
Naja, egal.
Ähm, ich hab nämlich zum Test schon eine dran gehängt, jetzt hab ich sie weggemacht, aber auch okay.
Ähm, hängen wir eine neue Platte dran.
New Disk.
Äh, Single File.
Äh, Disk irgendwie, keine Ahnung, also, 8 GB.
Bla.
Vierte Platte, zack, einschalten.
Ähm, ja, es ist an sich, ist die Idee nicht schlecht.
Also, es ist gar nicht mal so unlogisch aus Microsoft-Sicht, das zu tun, weil keine Sau, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, testet seine Anwendung und seine Webseiten auf Edge.
Oder kennt, kennt ihr irgendjemand, der seine Sachen auf Edge testet?
Also ich nicht, ich kenn keinen, der Edge ausprobiert.
Ernsthaft?
Okay, äh, ja, da hab ich nichts gesagt, aber, sag mal, die meisten, die meisten testen es nicht auf Edge.
So, und Microsoft hat jetzt ja vor, dass man quasi Web-Anwendungen in den Windows-Store irgendwie direkt pfeffern kann.
Und dementsprechend sollte der Kram natürlich auch ordentlich funktionieren und, äh, im Detail funktionieren Chrome und, äh, Edge halt nicht gleich.
Deswegen ist die Idee gar nicht so schlecht.
Mal eine Frage, wo du bei deinen Mainboards immer den optischen Soundausgang nennst.
Was ist der Vorteil davon über Klinke, dass du es nicht konvertieren musst?
Also wenn du einen Klinkenausgang hast, dann muss ja erstmal dein digitales Audio in analoges Audio, also halt in Stromschwankungen und Wellen und Gedöns, so halt in analoges Signal konvertiert werden.
Und geht dann zu entweder den Lautsprechern direkt oder zu irgendeinem Receiver oder sonst was, muss dann wieder umgewandelt werden.
Und mit dem optischen Ausgang ist halt das Schöne, du schließt es einfach an und es wird erst an der Stelle umgewandelt, wo dann auch, äh, es ausgegeben werden soll.
Ansonsten, ob du es wirklich hörst, äh, bei so Standard wage ich zu bezweifeln, ja.
So, und ich hab schon mal, ich hab schon mal auf die VM in Visual Studio installiert, wo wir das jetzt mit dem Festplattenformat hier ausprobieren können.
Nein, nein, nein, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Also, wir sehen's, wir haben eine neue Festplatte drin, 8 Gigabyte, äh, nicht initialisiert, nix und fertig.
Die sollten mal lieber den IE killen statt den Edge.
Den IE können sie nicht killen, also die haben ihn ja schon gekillt, soweit irgendwie, äh, möglich.
Allerdings, ähm, den IE selbst müssen sie drin lassen.
Die machen ja am IE auch nix.
Allerdings, es gibt so viele Anwendungen, die in irgendwelchen Unternehmen eingesetzt werden, die einfach IE brauchen.
Bitte Antwort auf was denn?
Was?
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, was ist das für eine Frage, WhiteLine58?
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, den Schulserver zu hacken?
Ist wichtig für meine Arbeit.
Wahrscheinlich gibt's die, ja.
Aber die Informationen sind halt absolut, äh, nicht ausreichend.
Den Schulserver, das ist so absolut nichtssagend, ja.
Das ist wie wenn ich sage, kann ich in dem Online-Spiel cheaten?
Wahrscheinlich kann's.
Ob's fertige Cheats dafür gibt, ist die Frage.
Wenn's ein verbreitetes Spiel ist, wahrscheinlich.
Wenn's nicht so verbreitet ist, vielleicht nicht.
Wenn's ein Konsolenspiel ist, wird's noch schwieriger.
Das ist, das ist viel zu breit gefragt, ja.
Ähm, aber nachdem die meisten, äh, Sachen, die in der Schule betrieben werden, meistens von Noobs betrieben werden,
also sprich entweder von Lehrern, die das in ihrer Freizeit machen,
oder teilweise sogar von irgendwelchen Schülern,
dann, ähm, muss man wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal großartig Hexsäuren und irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken finden, ausnutzen,
sondern man kommt wahrscheinlich schon relativ einfach, äh, drauf, indem man einfach Passwörter ausprobiert.
Hey, Max, war bei dir die Berufsschule auch so sinnlos?
Bin zum Glück bald fertig.
Ja, die war bei mir, genau, war auch extrem sinnlos.
Also, zum Thema Formatieren von Festplatten unter Windows.
Ich hab mich da im Vorfeld ein bisschen schlau gemacht.
Und zwar, es gibt wohl mehrere Möglichkeiten,
wie man eine Festplatte, äh,
nee, wie man eine Festplatte unter Windows formatiert, gibt's mehr,
wie man, wie man quasi, ähm, aus dem C-Sharp-Programm eine Festplatte unter Windows formatiert.
Die einfachste Variante ist, man würde zum Beispiel irgendwie, ähm,
einen Prozess starten und einfach irgendwie Diskpart oder so mit Parametern aufrufen.
Das würde funktionieren.
Die Sache ist,
nicht schön,
da man immer relativ schwierig, äh, quasi mitbekommt,
was denn ein externes Programm, was man startet, eigentlich genau macht,
beziehungsweise, ob es Fehlermeldungen gegeben hat, was der aktuelle Status ist und sonst was.
Also, quasi so ein Exakt im Hintergrund ist immer so ein bisschen unschön.
Ja, wenn's nicht anders geht, okay.
Also, das wäre die, das wäre die erste Variante, ja.
Man würde einfach irgendwie, äh, irgendwie so ein paar CMD-Befehle starten,
und dann hoffen, dass er auch alle Festplatten formatiert.
Die nächste Variante, die es gibt, ist, äh, PowerShell.
In PowerShell geht das auch.
PowerShell kann man sowas machen wie, Leute, ich muss mir erstmal Chrome installieren.
Ich muss mir erstmal in der VM Chrome installieren, sonst geht's nämlich, das funktioniert jetzt nicht.
Nein, wir wollen, wir wollen Google nicht unterstützen, genau.
Schließen.
Chrome.
Chrome, please.
So.
Das nächste, was ich gefunden hab, ist PowerShell Format Disk Windows.
Und man kann mit PowerShell sowas hier machen, wie Get Disks.
Wenn man das richtig schreiben könnte, dann kann man das auch machen.
Get Disks.
Ne, und der Disk, ja.
Da kriegt man hier zum Beispiel schon mal, welche Platten angeschlossen sind, ob sie formatiert sind oder nicht.
Und da gab's, da hab ich irgendwo einen Beitrag gefunden, wie man das macht.
Das heißt, die zweite Variante, allerdings leider nur minimal schönere Variante zum Festplatten formatieren, wäre, ähm, quasi anstatt Diskpart mit Parametern aufzurufen,
einfach nen kurzes PowerShell-Skript aufrufen, was das für uns macht.
Das ist natürlich auch unschön, weil ich krieg überhaupt nicht richtig mit, an welchen Stellen da was schief geht.
Das nächste ist, man könnte PowerShell in dem C-Sharp-Programm hosten und dort quasi schrittweise die Dinger machen.
Das ist aber auch nicht sonderlich schön.
Die nächste Variante, wie wir Festplatte formatieren können, wäre mit, äh, GUI-Automatisierung.
Das machen wir aber nicht, sag ich gleich dazu.
Also sprich, dass man Klicks simulieren würde, so Klicks, wie das hier machen im Endeffekt, ja.
Äh, initialisieren, hinzufügen, bla.
Das können wir aber gleich verwerfen, GUI-Automatisierung ist komplett von Arsch.
Da ist das Fenster mal ein bisschen weiter links und es funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das ist, das ist Mist.
So, und jetzt war ich so ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende, weil alles, was ich sonst so gefunden habe,
war, also wie man quasi Festplatten formatiert aus nem, aus nem, im Prinzip ist egal, ob's ein .NET-Programm ist oder sowas.
Oh, ich hab ne Donation gekriegt.
Ich hab meine, muss ich mal aufmachen.
Ich hab meine Anzeige gar nicht da.
Wartet mal.
Ist das schon mal, danke für die Donation, aber ich muss mal nachgucken.
Von Hardwareart, 5 Euro.
Kannst du bei dem Programm noch einfügen, dass der PC sich selbstständig zum Kunden verschickt?
Ähm, wenn du mir, wenn du mir, wenn DHL sowas anbietet, wenn DHL eine, eine Abholbeauftragungs, so blöd, ich weiß, ich weiß, dass du das eigentlich nicht ernst meinst, aber nur mal von der Idee her.
Ähm, wenn DHL eine Abholbeauftragungs-API anbietet, könnte man das theoretisch sogar machen.
Aber das, da muss man halt wirklich gucken, dass es richtig funktioniert, sonst beauftragt man DHL 50 mal was abzuholen, ohne dass sowas da ist.
Ist vielleicht keine allzu clevere Idee.
So, ähm, ja, und jetzt war ich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende, übrigens, wenn ich, äh, was übersehen, müsst ihr's einfach nochmal schreiben.
Ähm, ich kann grad nicht denken und, und, äh, progress machen.
Und jetzt war ich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende, wie wir das am schönsten machen.
Da hab ich halt mal ein bisschen weiter gesucht, so wie könnte man, wie könnte man beispielsweise, da hab ich mir Stack Overflow, so nach dem Motto Format, C-Sharp, äh, Disk, hab ich dann so ganz billig gesucht.
Dann findste dann irgendwie Formatting USB Drive, Formatting Drive, dann hab ich irgendwann das hier gefunden.
Und da wurd's dann schon langsam so Richtung, da ging's schon Richtung, Richtung schwarze Magie wieder von Windows.
Wo ich dann gesehen hab, aha, du machst hier irgendwie was.
Dann hab ich halt so, wie so nen, so nen, äh, WMI, äh, Objektsuch, so nen Win32 Volume Format.
Da bin ich allerdings auch nicht weitergekommen, weil ich gedacht hab, äh, weil ich festgestellt hab, okay, ich kann ja ne Sache nur formatieren, die schon partitioniert ist, die schon da ist.
Was wir ja nicht haben, wir haben ja ne komplett uninitialisierte, ne, äh, Disk ohne irgendwie Partitionen drauf, ohne MBR, ohne GPT, ohne alles.
Gar nix.
Und die nächste Sache, die ich gefunden hab, ich möge euch das jetzt nochmal zeigen, dass man mal sieht, wie absolut für'n Arsch das wieder unter Windows ist.
Die nächste Sache, die ich gefunden habe, nannte sich, ähm, wie hieß das, wie hieß das, das war ganz, ganz mir, ähm, hier genau, C-Sharp Win32 Disk.
So, und das war ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Da mussteste dann ganz merkwürdige Kernelaufrufe oder sowas machen.
Ne, das war jetzt Linux.
Ähm, ja.
Das war das hier, glaub ich.
Oder?
Ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar abgedrehtes Zeug.
Wo ich, das, was ich sogar ausprobiert hab, was ich versucht hab nachzubauen, was auch ein bisschen funktioniert hat, aber es wirklich so abgrundtief hässlich war, dass ich mir gedacht hab, das machen wir nicht.
Also, ich find, ich find jetzt die, ich find jetzt den eigentlichen Artikel nicht, den ich, den ich gefunden hab.
Aber es war wirklich ganz, ganz grausam.
Das waren irgendwie 300 Zeilen, äh, äh, Code mit irgendwelchem uralt Windows Zeug.
Ganz, ganz richtig eklig.
Was ist das hier?
Ich muss, ich muss mal den Source Code zeigen.
Das war so, so eklig.
Ich find's jetzt leider nicht mehr.
Aber das war wirklich Disk Management Control.
Oh ja, das war's.
Hier, so, so grausam, ey.
Ja.
Ne.
Den Artikel hatte ich auch.
Und es war so eklig, dass ich mir gedacht hab, nee, das mach ich nicht.
Da ruf ich lieber PowerShell auf.
Ja, hier, genau.
Das, das, das ist es.
Da, jede Menge Native Sachen, die der aufrufen muss.
Und das ist nur der Teil fürs Disk Initializen, ja.
Da ist auch kein Partitionieren und kein Formatieren dabei und auch kein Laufwerksbuchstaben-Mapping.
Also, ihr könnt euch vorstellen, dieses Geschwurbel von Windows-API-Calls mal 5.
Und dann hätte man die Sache ungefähr formatiert.
Ganz, ganz eklig.
Und dann hab ich irgendwann was gefunden.
Das nennt sich, ähm, Windows Storage Service oder irgendwie sowas.
Und da sieht man mal schon wieder, wie, wie viel Scheiße Microsoft mittlerweile für den gleichen Krempel hat.
Ähm, und das, das Ding hieß irgendwie dann, ähm, muss ich mal nachgucken, warte mal, das hab ich mir irgendwie aufgeschrieben.
Das hieß...
Windows Storage Service Management...
Hier, äh, MSFT heißt das.
MSFT.
Und das sind die, ähm, das ist nicht die, das mag die Abkürzung für Microsoft sein, aber das da mein ich.
So, dann hab ich das hier gefunden.
Das ist anscheinend relativ neu, seit Windows 2012 oder so.
Und das ist, äh, die Windows Storage Management-API.
Also quasi gefühlt die siebte Variante, die wir jetzt gefunden haben, wie man unter Windows Festplatten formatieren kann.
Und das ist das erste, wo ich sagen würde, ja, das ist halbwegs benutzbar.
Und ich hab damit schon ein bisschen rumgespielt und damit probieren wir heute mal, ob wir es schaffen, die Festplatte zu formatieren.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen langsamer, das Visual Studio hier, einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich innerhalb von einer, von einer, äh, VM bin.
Moin.
Oh nein, sieh.
So.
Und ich würde sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an.
Wir machen jetzt irgendwie mal eine, äh, public class disk formatter.
Könnte sein, dass wir das Ding gleich noch umbenennen.
So, und ich hab mir natürlich auch schon ein paar Beispiele rausgesucht im Vorfeld, wo ich rumgebastelt hab.
Das heißt, ich muss das jetzt nicht alles komplett, äh, raw machen.
So.
Und das erste, was man machen muss.
Also im Prinzip besteht das unter Windows.
Eine Festplatte zu formatieren besteht unter Windows aus vier oder fünf Schritten.
Das erste ist, man muss die, die Festplatte initialisieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was Microsoft darunter versteht, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber man muss es machen.
Man sieht hier nämlich auch, das Ding hier hat so einen Pfeil nach unten.
Und nachdem es, nachdem es initialisiert ist, wie gesagt, was auch immer das genau heißt, ähm, dann freut sich Windows.
Dann ist es initialisiert.
Danach musst du es partitionieren.
Nachdem du es partitioniert hast, musst du es formatieren.
Und wenn du es formatiert hast, dann kannst du dem neuen Volume ein Laufwerksbuchstabe zuordnen.
Also, unter Windows muss man das folgendermaßen machen.
Zuerst disk init.
Danach muss man, ähm, partitionieren.
Danach muss man formatieren.
Und danach muss man mappen.
So funktioniert das unter Windows.
Also im Prinzip das, was du unter Linux mit einer, einer Zeile machst.
Aber das, so ist das halt.
Wir sind, wir sind hier unter Windows.
Darf man nicht vergessen.
So, ähm, es ist wirklich übelst exploding brain, ja, also was man dafür machen muss.
So funktioniert das auch.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen uns jetzt erstmal, wir machen uns jetzt erstmal eine Methode, wo man eine Festplatte wieder löschen kann.
Wobei, nee, das bringt ja nichts.
Die ist ja schon leer.
Da weiß ich ja gar nicht, ob es funktioniert.
Alter.
Kannst, kannst du mal dieses.
So.
Exclusive Mode.
Da kann ich jetzt hier oben rumfuhrwerken, wie ich lustig bin.
Okay.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir brauchen mal für unseren Diskformat, da brauchen wir eine Public-Methode, die wir nennen.
Format all Disks.
Das ist so simpel von der API her, das kann jeder aufrufen.
So.
Und nun müssen wir, und das habe ich mir im Vorfeld schon rausgesucht.
Jetzt müssen wir folgendes machen.
Ähm.
Ich glaube, das hier ist das Richtige.
Copy, Paste.
So.
Jetzt muss man folgendes machen.
Und zwar, ich erkläre das gleich, was das Zeug, was das Zeug.
Warum kann ich das hier nicht includen?
Warum macht mein Visual Studio das nicht?
Warum muss ich das von Hand machen?
Was soll das?
System.
Was brauchen wir?
System Management.
System.
Wo ist es denn?
System Management brauchen wir.
Da ist der ganze Schmodder hier drin.
Was?
Nein, nein, nein.
Using.
Okay.
Ähm.
So.
Und was das hier jetzt macht, ist.
Das sagt, ich möchte.
Also, diese, dieses, dieses, ähm.
In System Management ist diese, wie, wie heißt das?
Windows Management Infrastructure Management.
Ne.
Äh.
Wie heißt das?
Was, was heißt WMI?
Was heißt WMI?
Äh.
Äh..
Was?
Äh.
Н navig anchor tô Windows management Instrumental min instru men tation à haz
so und wozu brauchst du ein programm das dir die disc formatiert dass dafür lieber liefert
windows doch schicke ui mit das habe ich doch bevor ich angehen da warst du auch schon da
das habe ich bevor ich angefangen habe doch 20 minuten lang erklärt das ist nicht für mich das
ist im management tool für hardware trainer wo sie ihre frisch aufgebauten rechner aktivieren
können und festplatten formatieren ich zeige es dir noch mal du hast du hast hier das management
interface du hast hier das web interface wurde deine ganzen windows keys drinne hast hier siehst
du wann rechner aktiviert wurden und dafür gibt es dann noch einen kleinen programm das hier was
die windows aktivierung macht und mac adresse und sowas übermittelt so und dieses kleinprogramm soll
jetzt nicht nur windows aktivieren können
sondern auch festplatten formatieren können und das muss natürlich automatisch funktionieren
moment ihr hört mich doch wenn ich die vm auf fullscreen mache oder würde mich doch weil nicht
dass ich die vm nicht dass ich die vm jetzt irgendwie meine soundcard gekrempft hat oder
sowas ist ja ist der klein progress oder kogas der server ist progress und der client ist kogas
weil
ich
gedacht habe dass eine gute idee das zeug so zu nennen
ich finde das übrigens da ist das wieder 120 leute am start sind um 19 uhr 50 am dienstag obwohl ich
jetzt schon wieder eineinhalb wochen kaum gestreamt habe oder eine woche ist es ungefähr her oder also
ich habe jetzt ja nicht mehr so viel gestreamt letzte woche wie wieder wie die woche davor aber
jetzt habe ich urlaub jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich jeden tag oder jeden zweiten tag wieder streben
sollen so genau und mit dieser
diese
wir haben gerade gelernt mit mittels windows management instrumentation
können wir jetzt sagen okay wir wollen alle festplatten die in dem
jeweiligen rechner drin sind wollen wir abfragen dazu muss man sagen wir möchten quasi innerhalb von wm diese microsoft windows
ist
dort management app in klassen verwenden
über WMI. Ich hoffe, das ist Windows-Technik so korrekt, wie ich das so sage. So, jetzt können wir hier alle Disks abfragen.
So, und ich zeige euch mal, dass wir auch wirklich alle Disks abfragen können damit.
Man kann jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen, er möge starten, bitte.
Achso, vielleicht soll ich erstmal, vielleicht soll ich nochmal sagen, wir wollen warten, nicht einfach beenden.
Und vor allem sollte ich erstmal sagen, New Disk Format, da soll ich das Ding erstmal anlegen.
So, jetzt aber.
So, das sind meine beiden Disks, die ich drinnen habe.
Geschwurbel 1, Geschwurbel 2, hier, Vmware Disks.
Von DesktopRinskvk68Q.
Eher Random-Name.
So, also wie man sieht, ich habe jetzt wirklich die beiden Festplatten abgefragt, wie man auch hier drinnen sieht.
Bezieht sich das an die Daten, die ich hier habe.
Bezieht sich das nur auf Disks, also auf, also keine CD-Laufwerke, die sind da nicht drinnen, halt richtige Disks oder SSDs.
Und, ja, so kann ich das Ganze abfragen.
Als nächstes, und das habe ich im Vorfeld auch schon nachgeguckt, als nächstes gibt es jetzt, wenn man sich jetzt hier mal anguckt bei Microsoft,
in diese MSFT-Disk-Class kann man wiederum selbst, ich habe keine Ahnung, welches Hirn sich das bei Microsoft ausgedacht hat,
das ist wirklich übermäßig kompliziert.
Welches Key-Tool? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen HR-Tool.
Ja, genau, der Klox hat es schon gemacht.
Da erkläre ich das.
Und das Tool ist an sich ja eigentlich soweit funktionsfähig, aber wie das halt so ist, sobald das quasi verwendet wird,
stellt man natürlich fest, was man sonst noch so alles einbauen könnte.
Und es gibt noch einige Sachen.
Heute machen wir das mit dem Festplattenformatieren ein.
So, und man kann jetzt wiederum, nachdem man jetzt alle, das soll sich mal verpissen hier oben, das komische, vor M-Wert gedünst da.
Nachdem wir jetzt hier alle Disks abgefragt haben, an dieser Stelle kann man jetzt wiederum auf diesem abgefragten WMI-Objekt,
kann man selbst wiederum Sachen aufrufen, weil sich Microsoft gedacht hat, das ist eine tolle Idee, das so zu machen.
Und diese, diese MSFT-Disk-Class.
Aus der Windows-Storage-Management-AP, die wir über die Windows-Management-Instrumentation abgefragt haben.
Also, dreht sich echt im Kopf alles rum, weil wir alle schon beim Aussprechen.
Darüber gibt es wieder eine Methode, die sich Initialize nennt.
Und die können wir jetzt aufrufen.
Und zwar, das kann man folgendermaßen aufrufen.
Man kann jetzt hier nämlich sagen, okay, achso, wir sollten uns jetzt vielleicht mal rausholen,
dass wir nur...
...die Disk formatieren, die leer ist.
Meine Systemplatte muss ich nicht unbedingt formatieren.
Wisst ihr was?
Heute kein Bock auf YOLO-Programming.
Wir machen mal einen Snapshot.
Wir machen mal einen Snapshot von der 4M, falls ich meine Systemplatte lösche.
Dass ich Windows nicht neu installieren muss, muss nicht sein.
So, und folgende Sachen kann ich jetzt quasi von jedem...
Wie gesagt, ich frage hier ja alle MSFT-Disk-Objekte ab.
Und diese Sachen werden mir da angeboten.
Unter anderem gibt es da sowas hier wie...
Wo ist es denn hier?
Es gab doch hier irgendwie sowas wie ID oder sowas.
Unique ID.
War das Unique ID?
Wir müssen zumindest die richtige Festplatte erwischen.
An der Stelle...
Ja, das könnte es gewesen sein.
An der Stelle übrigens...
Der Hinweis, das würde ich immer in der 4M machen.
Also falls ihr auch irgendwelche Sachen mit...
Wir formatieren Festplatten oder so.
Mal basteln wollt, macht das in der 4M.
Sonst kann es sein, dass ihr euer System schrottet.
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht, weil man keine Rechte hat mit seinem normalen User, das zu formatieren.
Aber es reicht ja auch schon, wenn man aus Versehen einen USB-Stick formatiert, den man nicht formatieren will.
Das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Hey Max, hast du eigentlich...
Hast du eigentlich ein Community-Squad oder sowas geplant?
Hier sowas ist schon Ewigkeiten geplant.
Ewig geplant, ja.
Leider, leider schon ewig geplant, ja.
So.
Und zwar, was das Ganze hier noch anbietet, ist ein...
Da ist es.
Partition-Style.
Das heißt, ich kann mir jetzt anzeigen lassen, von jeder Festplatte in meiner 4M oder in meinem Rechner, den Partition-Style.
So.
Die erste Festplatte hat Partition-Style 2.
Die zweite Festplatte...
Die dritte Festplatte hat Partition-Style 0.
Und dann kann man wiederum hier nachgucken.
Das eins muss man ja Microsoft zugute halten.
Die schreiben den Scheiß wenigstens auf.
Es ist zwar unglaublich konfus, das ganze Zeug hier, aber es steht wenigstens überall was da.
So, und man kann hier nämlich nachgucken, der Partition-Style wurde auch nicht.
Zumindest ist Partition-Style 0 nicht initialisiert.
Das habe ich schon rausgekriegt.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, wo es stand, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach, da steht es, genau.
Also Partition-Style bedeutet 0.
Partition-Style unknown.
Partition-Style 1 ist MBR und Partition-Style 2 ist GPT, also das Neue.
Partition-Table...
Was steht in GPT nochmal?
Global?
Ne.
Global Partition-Table?
Ne, was ist das?
Was steht in GPT?
Ah, ah!
GUID Partition-Table.
Ah, ja.
Das Zeug...
Ich frage mich immer, wer sich das alles immer auswendig merken kann, diese Abkürzungen.
Ich gucke immer einfach nach.
Was steht daneben?
Was ist da?
Ah, ja.
Was steht daneben?
Hahaha.
Lol.
Siehst du mal.
Das ist genau so, wie ich es gesagt habe.
Microsoft schreibt den Krempel wenigstens auf.
Ob ich es dann sehe, ist etwas anderes, aber Microsoft schreibt den Kram wenigstens auf.
Oh, geh weg, VMWare.
Du bist wirklich alt.
Don't show again.
So, Partition-Style.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt ein bisschen link-matchig machen.
Wir können sagen, WHERE partition-Style gleich 0.
Falscher Typ.
Äh, WHERE partition-Style.
String.
Das geht bestimmt schöner, aber mal gucken.
WHERE.
Oh.
Ah.
Okay.
Und jetzt kriege ich nur noch die Disks mit Partition-Style unbekannt.
Was bedeutet, noch nicht initialisiert oder sonst was.
So, dann nennen wir das Ding mal Disk.
Disk.
So, und jetzt können wir sagen, Disk Invoke.
Invoke-Method.
Ähm.
Clear.
Das brauchen wir auch noch gleich, damit wir den Kram wieder löschen können, den wir
da so fabrizieren.
Und Initialize.
Und Initialize bekommt übergeben ein Parallel.
Ein Parameter, wo man sagen kann, 1 für MBR und 2 für GPT.
Also, können wir jetzt sagen, äh, wie schreibt man das?
Initialize.
Und dann will er nicht.
Warum will er nicht?
Ah, weil ich den Parameter übergeben muss.
Oh, wie geht denn das?
Oh, wie geht das?
Wir übergeben einfach 0 und gucken, was passiert.
Okay.
Vielleicht ist ja GPT schon Standard und wir müssen gar nichts machen.
Also.
Von der Idee her, sollte jetzt diese Platte danach initialisiert sein.
Sie ist initialisiert.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Festplatte initialisiert.
Ist zwar noch nichts partitioniert oder sonst was.
Okay.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch eine zweite Methode, dass wir ordentlich testen können.
Äh.
Clear.
Disk.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal gefragt habe.
Aber wie stehst du zum Programmieren auf dem Zettel bei Klausuren?
Programmieren auf Zettel ist in der heutigen Zeit für absolute Basics vielleicht noch okay.
Aber alles, was ein bisschen...
Eigentlich ist es bescheuert, Programmieren auf Zettel.
Wir sind nicht mal 1990 oder so.
Ähm.
Man sollte den Leuten auch ordentliche Werkzeuge geben.
Ja.
Man muss es heute nicht auswendig können.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich weiß auch die meisten Sachen nicht auswendig.
Ich weiß ungefähr...
Dafür ist es auch mittlerweile viel zu vielfältig alles.
Ich weiß ungefähr, was man braucht.
Da wird Google angeschmissen.
Einfach geguckt.
Okay.
Wie hieß der Kram jetzt genau?
Und dann hat man es.
Man muss den ganzen Kram mal auswendig können.
C-Prüfung auf dem Zettel.
Auch noch C.
Also quasi eines der Programme, die wirklich noch am meisten von einer ordentlichen Entwicklungsumgebung
profitieren.
Ja.
Dann auch noch C.
So.
Wir brauchen jetzt sowas wie Clear Disk.
Brauchen wir.
Weil.
Ähm.
Wir müssen jetzt ja quasi vor jedem Durchlauf die Festplatte wieder löschen.
Weil wir sonst nicht wissen, dass unser Zeug funktioniert.
Na.
Das ist natürlich irgendwo klar.
Oder?
Okay.
Und nachdem wir wahrscheinlich diese Disk, dieses Disk-Getten hier noch sau oft brauchen
werden, machen wir mal eine eigene Methode draus.
Äh.
Ne.
Kein Problem.
Eine eigene.
Irgendwas wie ähm.
Äh.
Private Void.
Get Disks.
Oder.
Ja.
Property draus machen.
Get Disks.
Und dann kriegen wir da zurück ein Management.
Ein Enumerable of Management Object.
Kriegen wir zurück.
Ähm.
Zack.
Get Disks.
Ja.
So.
Und jetzt kann ich ja nämlich auch schon sagen.
Get Disks.
Äh.
Was hat er für ein Name?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Hä?
Ah.
Steht sogar da.
Genau.
Ähm.
Und das brauchen, werden wir wahrscheinlich auch öfters brauchen.
Und jetzt können wir das eigentlich vor mal in ein Property umwandeln lassen.
Das finde ich halt in Visual Studio auch ganz praktisch.
Da muss man den Scheiß, dieses nervige Zeug oftmals halt nicht mehr von Hand machen.
So.
Guck.
Und jetzt kriege ich jedes Mal, wenn ich äh Disks aufrufe, aktuelle äh Collection mit,
ähm, Festplatten.
Ja.
Und was die für einen Status haben.
So.
Jetzt kommen wir hier Initialize.
Jetzt brauchen wir die nächste Sache, die wir aufrufen.
Ist, äh, Clear Disc.
Das machen wir jetzt immer als erstes.
Clear Disc.
Weil wir wollen ja testen.
Und wir können nicht testen, wenn die Festplatte jedes Mal voll ist.
Also Clear Disc.
So.
Und Clear Disc ruft man folgendermaßen auf.
Wir brauchen wieder, ähm.
Warum mache ich eigentlich sowas hier?
Ist doch total beknackt.
Ähm.
Ha.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wir machen Clear Disc.
Ähm.
Wir machen Clear Disc äh, Nummer.
Und dann sagen wir das.
Disc.
Where.
Ähm.
Es gab hier irgendwie, irgendwie die Nummer von der, von der Platte konnte man sich
ausgeben lassen.
Ähm.
Number of Partitions.
Es gab hier irgendwie so eine, so eine eindeutige, ne, Unic ID meine ich nicht.
Number.
Gab es hier doch irgendwo.
Ähm.
Number.
I follow number.
Vmware.
Geh weg.
So.
Ähm.
Number gleich dem, den ich übergebe.
Und ich will, ich weiß in dem Fall, dass ich die erste will.
Ich will immer die erste.
Das schreibe ich dann hier unten rein.
Ähm.
Disc.
One.
Weil die erste ist meine Systemplatte.
Die zweite, also die erste.
Hier mit eins geht ja ab null los.
So.
Und dann schreibe ich hier unten rein.
Ähm.
Disc.
One.
Weil die erste ist meine Systemplatte.
Die zweite, also die erste.
Hier mit eins geht ja ab null los.
So.
Ähm.
Disc.
One.
Geh weg.
Hier mit eins geht ja ab null los.
Ähm.
Was hat der eigentlich für Schmerzen hier mit?
Ah.
Weil das ein Int ist und das hier ist ein.
Das ist kein String.
Das ist ein.
Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Ein Management Object.
Gut.
Ich meine, ich könnte sowas machen.
Aber das ist ja nur wirklich.
Das ist natürlich nur wirklich nicht, nicht schön.
Na.
Wartet mal.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wir gucken mal, was das hier ist.
Wir, wir, wir, wir gucken, wir gucken mal, was das hier ist.
Console Debugging.
Ach so.
Ähm.
Okay.
Ach Scheiße.
Da waren wir doch nicht.
Console Debugging.
Da waren wir doch.
Debugger.
Gucken, was da, was da drin steht.
Hallo?
Debugger.
Kannst du mir was anzeigen?
Ach ne.
Der hat das noch gar nicht ausgeführt.
Okay.
Discs.
Was ist denn in Discs drin?
Das sieht man jetzt nicht richtig, ne?
Das ist natürlich Kacke.
Kriege ich jetzt raus, was da drin ist?
Naja.
Egal.
Machen wir, machen wir es doch so.
Ähm.
Disc.
x first, last, weil wir wollen ja die zweite ist, last number, und dann gucken wir, was da drin ist, wahrscheinlich ein int oder sowas, ahja, ein unsigned int ist da drin, da können wir jetzt nämlich ein schönes neues C-Sharp, glaube 6 oder 7 Feature verwenden,
ähm, wir können nämlich sagen, wenn das da ein unsigned Integer ist, value, und value ist, ähm, gleich der Nummer, die wir übergeben haben, ja, genau, wir nehmen den ersten Eintrag, wo die Nummer gleich der übergebene Nummer ist,
also in dem Fall hier 1, so.
Das ist ein, ein, ein richtig, äh, richtig nice C-Sharp, ich glaube 6 Feature ist das.
Man kann das jetzt quasi in einem Statement machen, man kann jetzt quasi den Typ überprüfen, und im gleichen Statement gucken, ob der Typ, wenn das denn, wenn das denn von diesem Typ ist, ob es denn, ja, irgendwie ein anderer Vergleich halt zutrifft.
So, und jetzt können wir sagen, disk invoke, und jetzt einfach sagen, clear.
Null.
So, und jetzt sollte von der Idee her,
eigentlich, die Festplatte wieder, äh, ja, entinitialisiert werden.
Oh, es hängt.
Hängen ist schlecht.
Aber es ist wieder entinitialisiert.
Krasser Scheiß.
Okay, funktioniert.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt immer sagen, Format disk, also wir können jetzt immer sagen, clear disk, oder na, Format all disks.
Und wir gucken bei der ganzen Sache mal zu, wir sagen hier übrigens nochmal so eine Sache vorher, exit, so, dass wir wissen, dass wir fertig sind.
Nicht zugeordnet, okay.
Ja, nochmal starten.
Genau, er, er löscht es wieder.
Und danach initialisiert.
Das ist okay, das funktioniert gut.
Heißt, entinitialisieren, unmounted.
Pff, weiß nicht.
Das heißt, ja, das heißt, clear, du clearst.
Was, was macht er dann?
Removes partition information.
Ne, ne, ne, Moment.
Clear?
Clear, ja.
Machen wir.
Removes partition information and uninitialize disk.
Also wahrscheinlich, wenn er auch die Partitionsinformationen löscht, wird das wahrscheinlich auch unmounten, ja.
Und er stellt es hier irgendwie wieder auf, auf down oder so.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier für, was haben wir denn hier für Parameter zum Übergeben?
In, remove data.
True.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist.
Sollte man vielleicht machen, oder?
Äh, true.
If, if it's false or null, fail.
Remove data.
Remove OEM.
Nö, das brauchen wir nicht.
Zero out entire disk.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
Okay, wie.
Ach, guck mal, der Kawaii Shocks hat gerade geschrieben, wie das funktioniert.
Okay, Parameter.
Parameter.
Clear, also.
Schauen wir mal an, was das für Optionen gibt.
Ähm, Methodenname, also ich meine, allein schon, ganz ehrlich, Microsoft, ja.
Wenn die sowas anbieten, warum nicht in irgendeiner typisierten Variante?
Das muss ich hier mit komischen String-Gedönse rumbasteln, ey.
Da gibt's doch mittlerweile schönere Varianten, das ist doch echt ähnlich, äh, eklig, ey.
Das ist wirklich eklig, das Zeug hier.
Okay, clear.
Ähm, Object Array.
Willkommen im Jahr 2018.
Object Array.
Äh, Moment.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch so für Sachen?
Wartet mal.
Äh, Object Array.
Ein Management Operation Observer.
Was auch immer.
Management Base Object in Parameters.
Okay, das, das sieht, das hört sich ein bisschen typisierter an.
Und irgendwelche Invoke Method Options.
Aha.
Und das Ganze nochmal mit einem Management Operation Observer.
Microsoft, please.
Was, was ist denn da?
Was, was passiert da überhaupt?
Ist halt Low-Level-API.
Ja, deswegen muss man sie trotzdem nicht eklig zu benutzen machen.
Ja, Patrick, da hast du recht.
Management Operation Observer könnte, könnte, äh, glatt, glatt auf, aus Java kommen.
Wobei, in Java würde das Ding wahrscheinlich Management Operation Observer Factory Singleton heißen.
Das wäre der passende Java-Name davon.
Okay, also, was soll das denn da?
New Object Array.
Und dann müssen wir Parameter übergeben.
Über...
Übergibt man die der Reihenfolge nach?
Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Also, ich würde davon ausgehen, normalerweise übergibt man Parameter der Reihenfolge nach, sowas, wie es da steht.
Aber ich bin mir nachher bei Microsoft mittlerweile nicht mehr sicher, ne?
Remove Data.
Also machen wir jetzt sowas hier wie Remove Data True.
Danach sagen wir Remove More OEM.
Das ist doch nicht den hier ernst, oder?
Ähm, Zero Out Entire Disk.
Alter, ist das hässlich.
Was ist denn das hier?
Das sieht ja aus, wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend, ey.
Also, das fängt schon mal...
Ach du Scheiße, ist das...
Das ist ja massive hässlich, ey.
Erstmal fängt es schon mal an mit, dass man die Methode nicht direkt aufrufen kann, weil es eine Klasse dafür gibt.
Ich meine, so viel ist das nicht, ja?
Es gibt ein paar Klassen, aber es ist nicht so, dass es drei Milliarden wären, sondern, keine Ahnung, 30 oder so.
Man hätte es einfach...
Na?
Warte mal, gibt es denn GitHub?
GitHub MSFT.
Wrapper.
Das gibt es doch.
Das hat auch bestimmt schon irgendjemand für uns gebaut.
Aha.
Was?
Such mal nach Disk Utils.
Nein, wir wollen das nicht übersetzen.
Utility Libraries für Internet-Aufgaben.
Das ist falsch.
Ja, das ist schön.
Das ist gut.
Da muss man den Scheiß jetzt selbst machen.
Sehr, sehr nice.
ASMR Stream.
Sehr nice.
Setup Transporter.
Setup File.
Setup Complete.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal selbst.
Einfach, dass man rausklickt, wie das funktioniert.
Boah, 10++ Examples haut ab.
Könnte man sich mal angucken, ja.
Aber wir basteln das jetzt erstmal selbst.
Wobei, ich muss echt sagen, das ist schon...
Das ist an der Grenze des Zumutbaren hier, diese Geschichte.
Ich meine, Invoke Method und dann sagt man Clear.
Und dann die Parameter als Objekt.
Objekt Array.
Dann nicht mal als Param, sondern wirklich als Objekt Array.
Das heißt, ich...
Naja, egal.
Gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
So, uninitialize und jetzt wieder initialize.
Oder?
Ja.
Okay, es funktioniert.
Das will ich mich gar nicht so sehr beschweren.
Es funktioniert und damit ist es okay.
Ja, kann ich mitleben.
Okay.
Also, der erste Schritt ist gemacht.
Wir initialisieren die Only Empty Disks.
Also, wir initialisieren alle Festplatten, die leer sind.
Das ist doch schon mal ein guter erster Schritt.
So, als nächstes habe ich gesagt, als nächstes müssen wir das ganze Zeug partitionieren.
Und da habe ich auch schon rausgesucht, wie diese komische Klasse heißt.
Die wir dafür brauchen.
Also, ganz ohne Vorbereitung geht es hier auch nicht.
Hier, MSFT.
Ne, Moment.
Brauchen wir gar nicht.
Ha, ich habe mich verguckt.
Es gibt hier eine Create Partition Method.
Die brauchen wir jetzt an der Stelle.
So, das heißt, jetzt müssen wir sagen...
Oh, VM-Werk, geh weg.
Warum kommt das immer?
Ach so, weil ich raus tappe.
Logisch.
Wir wollen hässlichen Code sehen.
Oh, Leute, glaubt mir, das wird hässlich heute.
Das wird wirklich hässlich.
Das wird hässlich.
Das sieht schon hässlich aus.
So, als nächstes gibt es dann sowas wie Disk Invoke Method.
Und jetzt wird es abgedreht.
Jetzt müssen wir sagen...
Leute, wartet mal.
Ich muss noch kurz was zu trinken holen.
Na, wieder da.
So.
Wieder am Start.
Ich habe euch eigentlich erzählt, dass ich seit 15 Jahren vorhin mein erstes Netzwerkkabel
wieder selbst gekrimpt habe.
Und ich habe es natürlich beim ersten Anlauf gleich verkackt.
Weil ich es falschrum eingefädelt habe.
Beim zweiten Anlauf.
Beim zweiten Anlauf hat es funktioniert, nachdem ich es richtig eingefädelt habe.
Wartet mal.
Ich habe sogar irgendwo noch ein Bild von.
Wollte das eh mal auf der Doppelhosten.
Genau.
Hallo?
Kannst du mal aufgehen?
Klicken?
Jetzt?
Ja, jetzt geht's.
Warum sieht man den Chat nicht?
Sieht man den Chat?
Doch, klar sieht man den Chat.
Guck mal.
Wie ich es verkackt habe.
Falschrum.
Tja.
So rum ist richtig.
So rum ist falsch.
Ja gut.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich habe das 15 Jahre oder so nicht mal gemacht.
Aber jetzt funktioniert es.
Ich meine, es ist auch nicht sonderlich schön gemacht.
Hier unten muss man mal sagen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Aber der erste Anlauf ging komplett in die Hose.
Tja.
Aber ich war begeistert, dass ich das nach so einem Zeitpunkt gemacht habe.
Ich war begeistert.
Ich war begeistert, dass ich das nach so langer Zeit wieder fast im ersten Anlauf hingekriegt habe.
Ich meine, es ist nicht schwer, so ein Dings vorne auf ein Kabel zu packen.
Ja.
Aber es war schon mal nice, dass es wieder funktioniert hat.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Initialize Method.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Create Partition.
Wenn ich noch einmal dieses komische VN-Wert-Zeug da oben wegdrücken muss, drehe ich durch.
So, was brauchen wir denn da jetzt für Paran...
Oh, nee, oder?
Das ist jetzt nicht hier in Ernst.
Alter, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich soll doch jetzt nicht allen Ernstes...
Ich soll doch jetzt nicht allen Ernstes das hier als Object Array machen, oder?
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ja Folter.
Das ist verboten.
Oh, ich habe gerade fünf Tage...
Ich habe gerade fünf Tage abgestanden, das Wasser getrunken oder so.
Oh.
So.
Gibt es keinen Weg, das als Glas zu machen, oder wie?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Oh, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Was mache ich denn, wenn ich manche Sachen nicht übergeben will?
Zum Beispiel Assigned Drive Letter will ich nicht übergeben, weil Windows jedes Mal doofe Pop-Ups macht, wenn man das macht.
Okay, Size.
Size.
Oh, das ist ja nice.
Guck mal, Leute.
Wenn ich auf meinem zweiten Bildschirm scrolle, scrollt der hier mit.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Null.
Ja, wahrscheinlich muss ich Null übergeben.
Okay.
Size.
Null.
Auf geht's.
Use Maximum Size.
True.
Offset.
Null.
Nee.
Offset.
Null.
Lassen wir alles default.
Alignment.
Null.
Drive Letter.
Oh Gott, das tut ja weh beim Zugucken.
Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Drive Letter.
Assigned Drive Letter.
False.
MBR Type.
Null.
GPR Type.
Äh, Null.
Willst du mir das schon automatisch malen?
Okay, was haben wir noch?
Is hidden.
False.
Is active.
Das ist bestimmt ne MBR Geschichte.
False.
Ob das jetzt funktioniert?
Also wenn das funktioniert, ist das so.
Ist es der mit Abstand der hässlichste
Methodenaufruf, den ich je in meinem Leben,
ohne Scheiß, keine Übertreibung,
jetzt ernsthaft, ja, ist es der hässlichste
Methodenaufruf, den ich je in meinem Leben gesehen
habe.
Wenn das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert ernsthaft.
Boah, das ist ja zum Kotzen, ey.
Für sowas werden andere raus, weil die müssen
über Microsoft die Leute rauswerfen. Ich habe es mir ja nicht ausgedacht,
dass man den Kram so aufrufen muss.
Ich meine, wir könnten
da jetzt, ich meine, wir können es
ein bisschen, wir können es
ein bisschen weniger eklig machen.
Sowas wie, create
partition
und
wie könnte man das jetzt gescheit machen?
Also im Prinzip brauchen wir von den
Parametern ja nur, wir brauchen
ähm,
ja ne, schöner wird es nicht.
Wir müssen es ja letztendlich so aufrufen.
Schöner wird es nicht.
Ob ich da jetzt noch eine eigene Methode drum herum baue
oder nicht, ist ja vollkommen unerheblich.
Es muss so aufgerufen werden.
Aber wir machen da trotzdem mal eine eigene Methode raus.
Äh, Management, äh,
äh, ne, nicht Management.
Object, Disk.
Was läuft?
So.
Add partition, Disk.
Geht's noch?
Weggeschmissen, zack, ist wieder da.
Okay, es funktioniert noch.
Mach das Array unter anderem,
kommentiere die Zeilen, na, da hast du recht.
Boah, das ist hässlich.
Da krieg ich Ausschläge, wenn ich das sehe.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch für Varianten?
Da gab's ja noch mehr Zeug.
Es gibt hier StringMethod,
StringMethodName,
ObjectArray.
Und dann gibt's noch
ManagementObserver und das gleiche.
Und es gibt, guck doch mal,
da gibt's ein ManagementBaseObject
Parameters
und dann gibt es
InvokeMethodOptions.
Da gucken wir jetzt mal, was es da für
was es da für
Geschwubbel gibt von Microsoft.
So, Beispiele, Beispiele,
ha, nice.
Aber die richtige Methode ausgeht
immer aus StringMethod, blablabla, ja, haben wir.
Äh,
NewManagementClass, InParameters,
ProcessClass, Get
Method Parameters,
what?
Vor allem, ja, es geht mir echt auf den Keks da oben, das Zeug.
Also, was
jetzt genau?
Willst du mal was
Widerliches sehen? Das hab ich dir schon gerade genug.
Get
METHOD
CREATE PARTITION
Und was genau macht das jetzt?
What?
Moment, ich muss das jetzt erstmal checken.
Get METHOD
InParameters
OutParameters
What?
Ah, ja.
Ich glaub, ich hab's gecheckt.
Parameters
So, und jetzt sag ich hier Parameters
Äh
Kann man, kann man da eine Schleife?
Darüber machen?
Geht das? Nein, geht nicht.
Wie heißt das?
ClassPass
Container
Properties
Item
Okay
Name
Hab ich gesehen. Und was haben wir ansonsten noch hier?
Type
Value
So, next
Aha, Moment, nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, was sich Microsoft dabei gedacht hat, weil es so scheiße ist, eine Methode auszurufen mit einem Object Array kann ich mir quasi dieses Object Array schon quasi vorher erstellen lassen und und bekommen dann ein Objekt zurück, wo ich irgendwie zur Laufzeit das.
Befügt.
Ja, aber wo genau ist denn jetzt da der Vorteil von?
Ich mein, wenn ich, wisst ihr, wenn ich jetzt hier machen könnte, so, so, so, so nach dem Motto, ne, wenn ich jetzt so machen könnte, Try Flatter, dass ich das sehen würde, okay, dann, dann, dann würde ich's noch verstehen, aber, ja, aber okay, es ist doch, es ist doch, es ist ein Ticken, es ist ein Ticken hübscher.
Man, man könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich hier sowas machen, Parameters, äh, wie hieß der Kram, äh, Use Maximum Size.
Ja, ich muss nämlich nicht nullen, ich muss den Kram nicht nullen, sondern ich kann einfach, mach einfach nur das, was ich, was ich brauch.
So, und wir, wir brauchen, was brauchen wir, Offset brauchen wir nicht, Alignment, Try Flatter brauchen wir nicht, Assigned Try Flatter wollen wir False, ähm, MBR-Tablet ist, ist Hidden, ist Hidden und ist Active, wollen wir noch False, ist Hidden False, ist Active False, Aktuive.
So, und jetzt rufen wir den Krams nochmal auf.
Mit das hier als Parameter drinnen, geht nicht, weil, bla, ich hab noch was vergessen, wir brauchen noch Invoke Method Options, Invoke Method Options, Management, Named, ach, wisst ihr was, gucken einfach mal, was passiert, wenn ich da was Leeres reinschiebe.
Moin, was soll das mal werden, mach mal ein Ausrufezeichen, HR Tool.
Dann siehst du, was das Ganze wird und das ist ein Teil davon, also, beziehungsweise, es funktioniert ja alles schon, wir basteln aktuell noch in unseren Client ein, dass man automatisch Festplatten von neu aufgebauten Rechnern formatieren kann.
Das ist für einen, das ist ein Tool für einen Laden, der viel Hardware zusammenbaut und, ähm, quasi nach dem Installieren seine frisch aufgebauten Rechner,
gerne partitionieren, aktivieren möchte, mit History, ich kann's dir ja mal kurz zeigen, äh, mit History, wer, wo, wann was aktiviert hat, ja.
Also, hier hast du zum Beispiel, hier hast du jetzt deine Übersicht von noch verfügbaren Windows-Keys, jeweils mit einem Kommentar dabei, ähm, weißt du, zum Beispiel, wann man die hinzugefügt hat.
Und hier siehst du zum Beispiel, welcher Rechner wann aktiviert wurde, kannst du nachgucken.
Oh, da hast du noch so komische Übersichten, wie, ähm.
Ähm, ist noch sehr roh hier an der Stelle, hab ich noch nicht, außer das Diagramm hier viel reingemacht, wie viele Rechner am Tag aktiviert wurden und sowas.
Ach ja, und die Windows-Keys sind übrigens nicht echt, genau.
Die man hier gerade sieht.
Oh, ist ActiveCourse, richtig.
Genau, und aktuell aktiviert das Ding bloß Windows und, äh, in Zukunft soll es halt auch noch Festplatten formatieren können und einfach den nächstgelegenen Laufwerksbuchstaben zuordnen.
Aber an dieser Stelle noch nicht, weil ich zeige euch mal.
Was passiert, wenn wir das machen?
Windows ist dann nämlich ultra nervig.
Das kenne ich von USB-Sticks.
So, gucken wir auch gleich mal, ob das funktioniert.
Sobald man nämlich dem Ding den Laufwerksbuchstaben zuordnet, Pop-Ups ohne Ende.
Will ich, äh, geh weg.
Windows!
Please, Microsoft.
Deswegen sagen wir hier, assign try-flatter false.
So, okay.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe.
Wir können jetzt, äh.
Festplatte initialisieren.
Was, wenn ich es jetzt richtig gesehen habe, bei Windows so viel bedeutet, wie ein GPT drauf machen oder ein MBR drauf machen.
Ähm.
Danach.
Ja, komm, da sind wir jetzt mal ordentlich.
Wir sagen noch private.
Priviet, nee.
Private.
Ich kann ja mal schreiben.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Äh, init.
Disk.
Machen wir da auch noch mal eine eigene Methode draus.
Ähm.
Und da.
Gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert hat, weil wir kriegen ja hier irgendwie ein.
Ein Object zurück.
Result.
Return.
Ähm.
Result.
Wir müssen uns das Ganze mal angucken.
Wir müssen uns mal angucken, was da eigentlich jetzt genau zurückkommt.
Result.
Wahrscheinlich, ich denke mal, entweder Return-Value null oder einfach nur null.
Äh.
Oder auch nicht.
Also, wir sollten das Ganze vielleicht noch aufrufen.
Äh.
Disk.
Init.
Äh.
Null.
Ja.
Auskernfuchs sagt, Timerx kennst du nicht.
Was?
Kannst du nicht einfach die Übergabe-Arrays als Tracks machen und dann per Reflection in
ein Array konvertieren?
Die Idee ist gar nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, das kommt ja hier nicht auf die Geschwindigkeit an oder so.
Die Idee finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Das wäre eine Option, ja.
Das merke ich mir mal.
Das machen wir vielleicht.
Die Idee finde ich nicht schlecht.
Man müsste dem Struck natürlich gucken, dass man die...
Nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Weil wir null brauchen als Felder.
Und du kannst Struck...
Du kannst Struck...
Ähm.
Oder?
Doch, das müsste gehen.
Das könnte ja...
Alter.
Die VM spackt heute mega rum, ey.
Ja.
Das müsste noch gehen.
Ich könnte sowas hier machen.
Struckt.
Was ich...
Äh.
Format.
Parameter.
Nee.
Äh.
Wie heißt...
Partition.
Params.
Ah, das müsste funktionieren.
Ja, aber da müsste ich alle...
Alle reinmachen und...
Das muss ich mir nochmal überlegen.
Also, ich glaube, ich werde es erstmal so lassen.
Das ist ja auch halbwegs lesbar mit diesem Gedingse hier.
Ist die Musik kaputt?
Na gut.
Chat ist so ruhig.
Was ist denn heute los?
Das muss...
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich muss euch mal kurz aufwecken.
So.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid wieder wach.
Cute Chat.
Ah, ja, ja.
Ich habe mir letztens ein Video angeguckt.
Der...
Was es genau damit auf sich hat.
Ja.
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich mir das gemerkt.
Ich weiß jetzt da, dass es da um...
Bei dieser Ayaya-Geschichte irgendwie um britische Austauschschülerinnen in Japan geht.
Also so das, was ich als japanischer Anime-Ersteller so ausdenken.
Ja, und das englische Austauschgrill läuft natürlich schön in Englandfarben rum.
Weil sich das Japaner so ausdenken.
Weil das natürlich auch jede Austauschschülerin mit Sicherheit macht,
in englischen Farben dann in der Schule rumlaufen.
Vor allem, wer hat eine Schuluniform in englischen Farben? Warum?
Egal, japanische Logik.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Max ist der Mega-Weeb-Confirm.
Na klar, was meinst du, warum ich solche Emotes überhaupt habe?
Huh? Weeb-Confirmed.
Confirmed.
Ähm, so, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Jetzt mal, create partition.
Me weep, me, was, me weep, I spam, mod, bugger, if, ban.
So, okay, wir haben jetzt, also, wir haben jetzt die Festplatte initialisiert,
wir haben die Festplatte-Partition created
und als nächstes müssen wir die Festplatte formatieren.
Und dazu können wir,
Jack,
dazu können wir folgende Klasse verwenden, und zwar MSFT-Volume.
Das da, das wird jetzt noch ekliger wahrscheinlich.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir, jetzt kriegen wir nämlich ein MSFT-Volume.
Also, kriegen wir nicht, also müssen wir uns raussuchen.
So, das heißt, VM-Währ.
Ich raste gleich aus mit dem Kram.
Da oben, ja.
So, das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt noch sowas hier.
Nicht nur mit Disks, sondern mit Volumes.
Und dazu brauchen wir MSFT-Volume.
Das heißt nämlich, wir kriegen jetzt ein Volume,
nachdem wir die Festplatte partitioniert haben.
Das nennt Microsoft dann einfach so.
Volumes.
So, das heißt, probieren wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Äh, keine Ahnung, Last.
Äh, und was gibt's da für Sachen?
Drive-Flat habe ich Path.
Gehen wir uns mal aus.
Oder File-System.
File, in der File-System ist ja noch keins drauf.
Path, gehen wir mal aus.
So.
Was sollten wir jetzt kriegen, nachdem die Festplatte erstellt wurde?
Äh, nachdem die Partition, Partition eingelegt wurde.
Volume.
Okay, kriegen wir.
Ich weiß jetzt allerdings nicht, ja, wie kann ich denn das jetzt mappen gescheit?
Wie kriege ich das jetzt?
Wie kriege ich das jetzt raus?
Oh, das ist jetzt kompliziert.
Ähm.
Wie kriege ich denn jetzt raus, welches Volume auf welcher Platte ist?
Kennst du Diskpart-Exe?
Ja, klar.
Das habe ich ja gleich, das habe ich auch am Anfang erzählt.
Ähm, das ist so quasi, das wäre die naheliegendste Variante,
dass wir einfach Process, Create machen und dann Diskpart aufrufen.
Aber es ist immer schwierig zu kontrollieren,
was extern aufgerufene Programme treiben.
Also, ob es jetzt einen Fehler gegeben hat oder nicht.
Also, es ist besser, wir machen die Schritte selbst.
Das ist auf jeden Fall robuster und zuverlässiger und außerdem lernt man was bei.
Wie kriege ich das denn jetzt gemappt?
Woher weiß ich denn jetzt, welches Volume?
Ha.
Moment.
MSFT Partition gibt es ja auch noch.
Äh, welche Tastatur hast du?
Ich habe eine Corsair X95.
Corsair X95 Platinum.
Volumes sind ja Disk, USB und DVD.
Ne, ne, ne, Volumes sind quasi von Festplatten logische Partitionen irgendwie unter Windows.
Keine Ahnung, das ist nicht, es ist nicht zwangsläufig unbedingt Disk, USB und DVD.
Zum Beispiel eine unformatierte Disk ist kein Volume.
Ich versuche da auch gerade durchzublicken, was Windows unter verschiedenen Sachen verschwendet.
Steht.
Okay, also.
Partition.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt zu...
Ah, Disk Number.
Das gab es hier oben doch auch.
Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Disk Number.
Ja, wunderbar.
Ein Number gibt es hier.
Disk Number.
Partitions.
Also brauche ich den ganzen Schmodder hier oben nochmal für Partitions, oder was?
Okay.
Partitions.
Was ist denn hier?
Partition.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert jetzt so.
Partitions.
Part...
Kann er mal schreiben.
Okay.
So.
Also.
Von der Idee her.
Achso, das sollten wir vielleicht noch fertig machen hier.
Result.
Also, return to...
Result ist int.
Das haben wir doch hier unten schon mal irgendwo gemacht.
Äh, value und value gleich.
Value gleich gleich null.
Result.
Gut, so.
Wir machen nur weiter, wenn...
...InitDisk erfolgreich war.
Ja, siehbar.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich mir letztens angeguckt habe.
Irgendeiner hat 15 Minuten lang Eierjahr erklärt.
Aber ich habe mich verschrieben.
Partitions.
Parti...
Ah, ja, ja, ja.
Ah.
Aber gut, dass der Chat aufpasst.
Hey, Max, was programmierst du gerade?
Ein Tool, das mir Festplatten...
Also, Teil vom Hardware-Tool, das mir Festplatten...
...unbenutzte Festplatten formatiert und in nächstgelegene Laufwerksbuchstaben gibt.
Weil das den Jungs noch eingefallen ist, dass das noch ganz praktisch wäre.
Das ist ja auch irgendwie logisch, klingt, ne?
Je weniger du von Hand machen musst am Rechner, umso besser.
Okay.
So, dann ist Partition.
Where Partition...
Oh ja, Disk Number gleich Disk Number.
Kann man das... geht das so?
So, weil das hier ist jetzt...
Das ist die Partition, die ich gerade erstellt habe.
Muss so sein.
Weil, von der Logik her, hier ist die Festplatte komplett leer.
Ähm, hiernach hat sie einen MBR oder einen GPT, in dem Fall einen GPT drauf.
Danach hat sie eine Partition drauf, die so groß ist wie das komplette Laufwerk.
Und das heißt, wenn ich jetzt die einzige Partition suche, die auf dieser Festplatte ist,
die auf dieser Disk ist,
dann...
...wirst du das so funktionieren.
Ja, gucken wir mal, ob er die findet.
Ja, ne, Drive-Info ist nicht...
...featurereich, beziehungsweise low-level genug.
...genug dafür.
Du kannst mit Drive-Info, kannst ein paar Sachen nachgucken, aber ich glaub...
...ich glaub, du kannst sogar formatieren mit Drive-Info, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab noch.
Aber du kannst halt keine Festplatten initialisieren, du kannst keine, ähm...
...Partitionen anlegen.
Und solche Dinger.
So, Partition.
Jetzt hab ich eine Partition.
So, und wie krieg ich denn jetzt bei einem Volume raus?
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt bei einem Volume raus?
Dass dieses Volume auf dieser Partition ist.
Wie funktioniert das denn jetzt?
Wie krieg ich das raus?
Exit Path.
Exit Path klingt gut.
Schau mal mal.
Was da rauskommt.
Partition.
Exit Path.
Wenn ich Glück habe, steht da jetzt das Volume drin.
Ähm.
Äh.
Oh, ich muss den Kram irgendwie noch casten.
Okay.
Was ist denn nun mit Casten los?
Ne.
Äh.
Wo ist das Problem?
Achso.
Moment, ist noch plötzlich.
First wollen wir haben.
Ja.
Ha.
Warum nicht?
Ah, wahrscheinlich weil mein Vergleich wieder am...
Weil wieder mein Vergleich für den Arsch ist.
Ich wette mit euch, das funktioniert jetzt.
Das kann doch auch nicht sein.
Warum muss das denn so hässlich sein?
Das kann ich nicht einfach...
Warte.
Okay, Moment.
Geht das jetzt?
Try and Error.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Also das muss ja...
Da muss ja was drin sein.
Ah.
Object.
Okay.
Ah.
Moment, ist das 0?
Warum ist das 0?
Ich blicke gerade nicht durch.
Der findet hier doch was, oder?
Partition.
Disk Number.
Oh.
Hei, Gott, ist das scheiße zu verwenden, ey.
1.
Ja, das ist richtig.
So, und warum kann ich jetzt nicht sagen?
Partition.
Access Path.
Warum geht das nicht?
Muss doch funktionieren.
Ach so, ja klar, weil es noch keine gibt.
Da ist ja auch keine...
Da ist ja auch...
Da ist ja noch nichts formatiert drauf.
Ja, da ist ja auch noch nichts formatiert drauf.
Deswegen gibt es da auch keine Access...
Kein Access Path.
Wäre ja eigentlich irgendwie logisch, ne?
Wie komme ich denn jetzt?
Was?
Von der Partition zum Volume.
Wie komme ich jetzt von der Partition zum Volume?
Da bin ich jetzt irgendwie überfragt.
Da bin ich jetzt echt überfragt.
Wie komme ich denn jetzt von der Partition zum Volume?
Weil nur das Volume darf ich formatieren.
Tja.
Wie komme ich jetzt vom...
Das, äh...
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Aber wir sind ja auch noch am forschen, wie das funktioniert.
Aber Disc Number geben wir mal aus.
Dann geben wir nochmal aus...
Ähm...
Partition Number.
Access Path lassen wir mal sein.
Partition Number 1.
Disc Number 1.
Ja.
Okay.
Ähm...
Gibt es sowas wie...
Path.
Komme ich damit irgendwie weiter?
Ich meine, wie...
Wie?
Ich brauche jetzt sowas...
Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt eine Partition.
Ich habe eine Partition erzeugt.
Ich brauche jetzt eine...
MSFT Volume.
Eine MSFT Volume brauche ich.
Dass ich formatieren kann.
Partition to Volume.
Okay.
Genau, weil nur diese Volume-Klasse kann man formatieren.
Die Sache ist jetzt...
Wie bekomme ich denn jetzt von der Partitions...
Hat das hier vielleicht Access Path oder so?
Also wenn ihr Ideen habt, nur her mit.
Ähm...
Weil ich meine Access Path...
Das ist auch leer.
Kann das daran liegen, dass Access Path ein String-Array ist?
Eigentlich nicht, weil...
Das hier gibt jetzt wahrscheinlich 2.
Das ist wahrscheinlich 0.
Das ist 0.
Das heißt, das kann kein String-Array sein.
Ah, ich meine...
Bis zu dem Schritt funktioniert der Kempel jetzt.
Create Partition.
Das wäre das vielleicht noch irgendwie Flaschen oder so?
Kann das sein?
Was mir die irgendwie sagen muss...
Ne, Flaschen gibt es auch noch da.
Okay, dann gibt es Partition to Volume.
Was ist denn das für ein Kempel schon wieder?
Alter, Microsoft, please.
Warum ist das so kompliziert?
Kann doch nicht sein.
Okay, Stack Overflow.
Where Drive Letter?
Nein, wir haben doch kein Drive Letter.
Partition to Volume.
Where Partition?
Ah.
Oh, nee, das ist hässlich.
Das ist ja mega hässlich, ey.
Das ist ja mega hässlich.
Partition to Volume.
Where Partition?
Oh, das ist echt eklig.
Kotzgeflext.
Also, was jetzt genau?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Probieren wir jetzt mal.
Probieren wir jetzt mal, ob das funktioniert.
Bla, bla, bla.
Partition to...
Where Partition gleich...
Partition...
Past.
Na, ob das was wird?
SQL bei Partition...
Das ist Microsoft, ja.
Nee, das ist...
Das ist Windows Management Instrumentation oder irgendwie sowas.
WMI.
Da kann man ganz viel machen.
Nicht nur partitionieren.
Aber es ist wirklich...
Es ist grausam.
Vorsicht.
Es ist wirklich ganz, ganz grausam, ey.
Okay.
Also, ich teste.
Test.
Test 2.
Ist mir doch vollkommen egal.
Hauptsache, es tut.
Hau mal anders.
Vorschleife.
Was macht das Dollar Form String?
Das ist ein neues C Sharp, ich glaube, 7 Feature.
Das ist String Interpolation, was es quasi schon in einer ziemlich anderen Sprache gibt.
Dollar Form String sorgt dafür, dass du, wenn du hier...
Du schweifst die Klammer.
Machst kannst du da drin Logik einsetzen oder Variablen direkt im String.
Das heißt, du musst die Dinger nicht mehr mit Plus oder so zusammen machen.
Du brauchst kein Stringbilder mehr.
Du brauchst kein Stringformat mehr.
Kannst es einfach so reinhauen an der Stelle.
So, mal gucken, ob der Krempel jetzt funktioniert.
Die Anfrage ist ungültig.
Ah, gedrackt.
Warum ist die denn ungültig?
Mein Gott, das ist echt ein komplizierter Kack, ey.
Was ist das hier für ein Geschwuppel, ey?
Okay, wir gucken uns noch mal diesen Pfad an.
Partition Path.
Der sieht aber auch ganz anders aus als da, ne?
Das Beispiel von dem sieht komplett anders aus.
Disk ID.
Na doch, im Prinzip sieht es genau so ähnlich aus.
Nur, dass der davor noch irgendwie Slash, Slash, Slash Punkt hat.
Und dann Root.
Alter, ist das wieder ein Kack, ey.
Soll ich das mal davor machen?
Ich mach das mal davor.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was es tut, aber vielleicht bringt es ja was.
Ach so, vielleicht sollte man das jetzt noch mal getten.
Oh, das hat funktioniert?
Das hat jetzt funktioniert, oder was?
Oh, das ist wieder so absolute schwarze Magie, der Krempel, ey.
Microsoft, was soll das denn?
Come on, bruh.
Ne.
Warum ist die Anfrage denn jetzt ungültig und eben war sie noch nicht ungültig?
Ah, da schaut keiner erstmal drauf, ey.
Partition to Volume.
Gibt es da noch mehr Beispiele für?
Ja, Partition...
Jetzt mal, sag mal, wie viele Striche macht er denn jetzt noch davor?
Das hört ja gar nicht mal auf.
Ah, Moment, warte mal, sind das Backslashes?
Ah, ne, wir haben ein Add davor, alles gut.
Alles gut.
Ah, ne, das sind Backslashes.
Wartet mal, Leute.
Wartet mal.
Wir müssen noch, wir müssen noch die Backslashes escapen.
Fuck.
Leck mich am Arsch, ey.
Meine Güte, Microsoft, was ist das denn wieder?
Okay, wir machen es mal anders.
Wir fragen alle ab.
Wir fragen mal alle ab, ob das funktioniert.
Ah, okay, das...
Das geht, das geht.
So, und was kriegt man, was kriegt man in dieser komischen...
Partition to Volume, was kriegt man da raus?
Man kriegt ne...
MSFT Partition.
Das ist eines der hässlichsten Sachen, die ich...
...durch die letzten Jahre gesehen hab, dieses Kram.
Würde man sich ja denken.
Ich mein, es sollte kein großer Akt sein, eine Festplatte zu formatieren.
Aber...
...ist es anscheinend.
Na, wat?
Wie nicht gefunden?
Microsoft sagt, dass der Kram...
Ach, ne, ha, ich hab mich verguckt.
Okay, sorry.
Volume und Partition.
Jaja, ich hab mich verguckt.
Okay, ähm...
Dann geben wir jetzt mal hier die Partition aus.
Und da drunter...
...geben wir...
...von meiner eigentlichen Partition...
...geben wir den Kram auch mal aus.
So, und danach machen wir irgendwie so ein Trenn...
...Dings drunter.
Gucken, was er ausgibt.
Da gucken wir uns mal den Unterschied an, was denn angeblich hier falsch ist.
Aha.
Da ist der Desktop-Name vorne weg.
Warum sind da... Warum ist der...
...in der Fahrt da schon wieder komplett unterschiedlich?
Das ist wirklich absolut...
...grausam, ey.
Hat hier jemand ein bisschen Ahnung von...
...WordPress beziehungsweise Web-Development?
Schieß los! Ich krieg eh grad die Krise...
...mit Microsoft-Gedöns.
Was? Ich meine...
...wer denkt sich denn so Dinge hier aus?
Äh, was ist das denn?
Alter.
Okay, wo haben wir denn jetzt das Gleiche?
Was haben wir das ungefähr, was was entspricht?
Hä?
BF1D...
Ja, das hier, das hier. Die letzten sind...
Die letzten sind die, die...
Also das hier, das hier müsste übereinstimmen.
Okay, was müsste ich denn machen, dass das übereinstimmt?
Root...
Object...
Das stimmt überein, oder?
Das einzige ist da...
Das einzige ist, dass hier vorne...
Hier vorne...
Rechnernamen davor...
Und hier, hier steht...
Warum auch immer, ey? Meine Fresse, ey!
Ja, und hier steht davor...
Ähm...
Slash...
Soll ich allen Ernstes jetzt mit irgendwelchen...
Regex-Gedöns da dran rumsegen?
Oder was?
Microsoft, was ist das?
Und ich meine, warum gibt's denn überhaupt sowas hier wie...
Wie PaaS, ja?
Wir machen das Ganze nochmal...
Warum kann ich mir das überhaupt hier ausgeben lassen, wenn es doch eh überhaupt nicht stimmt?
Oh...
Okay...
Ah ja, da machen wir das so...
Also...
Okay, also schneiden wir das hier jetzt weg, oder was?
Schneiden wir das hier weg und setzen...
Und setzen...
Slash, slash, Punkt...
...davor.
Wieso kann man eigentlich nicht subben?
Weil ich immer noch kein Twitch-Partner bin.
Ich hab immer noch nicht mal das Formular ausgefüllt.
Also...
Der Kribo97133 schreibt...
Ich glaube, dass meine Seite...
...langsamer gemacht wird, weil der Browser...
...versucht, 404er-Links zu laden.
Ich weiß nicht, an welcher Stelle...
...die 404 entstehen.
Ich würde sehen, wie ich das eliminieren kann.
Also in der Regel lädt ein Browser ja keine Links.
Einfach nur, weil sie da sind.
Es sei denn...
Du hast halt...
...zum Beispiel nen Include...
...von irgendwelchen...
...JavaScript-Zeugs oder...
...irgendwelches CSS-Zeug...
...oder so. Na, dann kriegst du natürlich...
...bem Nachladen einen 404.
Aber...
...mich würd's wundern, wenn ein 404...
...das wirklich...
...langsamer machen sollte, weil...
...ein 404 ist in der Regel ja eigentlich...
...eher schneller.
Weil...
...wenn du jetzt nen JavaScript-Zeugs lädst...
...und du das ausführst, dann dauert das...
...ne ganze Weile.
Kriegst du beim Downloaden von nem JavaScript...
...ne 404, da kann dein Browser sagen...
...ja, scheiß drauf, ich mach einfach nix an der Stelle.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, wie man mit nem 404...
...einen Browser langsamer machen soll.
Also, da fällt mir jetzt auch nix zu ein.
Gerade...
...jetzt mal davon abgesehen, wenn das deine Seite ist...
...warum...
...lässt du denn Sachen überhaupt laden, die es nicht gibt?
Ja, dann lass...
...also, ich mein, vielleicht klingt's jetzt aus meiner Sicht...
...einfach zu naheliegend, aber...
...wenn das doch deine Seite ist, dann lad doch einfach nicht...
...Dinger, die nicht da sind, oder...
...was versteh ich an der Stelle nicht?
...WordPress. Ah!
Achso! Ah, WordPress!
Oh, pff...
Achso, deine...
...WordPress-Seite...
...hat nen Plugin drin, und dieses Plugin lädt...
...quasi...
...äh...
...von sich Seiten Dinger nach, die...
...nicht da sind.
Also, das erste...
...was ich machen würde, ich würd mal...
...gucken, ob es...
...ne aktuelle Version von dem Plugin gibt...
...und wenn nicht...
...würd ich das Plugin mal deaktivieren...
...wie gesagt, ich hab von WordPress auch nicht so die...
...großartige Ahnung, aber...
...ich würd das Plugin einfach mal deaktivieren...
...und gucken, ob's danach schneller ist...
...dann hat man das zumindest schon mal eingegrenzt...
...ob's jetzt an diesem Plugin liegt, oder nicht...
...ja, und wenn's...
...an diesem Plugin liegt, dann...
...sind das ja meistens...
...also, wenn das irgendein Open Source Plugin ist, auf GitHub...
...dann würd ich dem Autor mal schreiben, warum er da so...
...komische Dinger reinschreibt...
...und ansonsten...
...je nachdem, was es für Links sind...
...kannst du die ja vielleicht auch im Plugin...
...Code austauschen, ja, also sprich, wenn der...
...irgendwelche JavaScript-Libraries...
...nachladen will, halt von Adressen...
...die es nicht mehr gibt, suchst du dir halt...
...ne Adresse raus, wo es das noch gibt...
...und änderst das...
...das ist aber halt jetzt individuell, je nachdem, was das...
...genau machen will...
...ja, was...
...was versucht er denn zum Beispiel zu laden, was...
...den 404 gibt...
...also ich würd generell erstmal das Plugin deaktivieren und wirklich...
...gucken, von welchem Plugin das Ganze kommt...
...Leute...
...ich hab keinen Bock mehr, dieses komische Microsoft-Zeugs...
...hier rumzuschnibbeln...
...das ist mir zu dumm...
...das ist mir wirklich zu...
...zu nervig gerade...
...ich will jetzt da auch nicht...ich will...
...ich will eigentlich da dran ja gar nicht rumregexen...
...oder Stringcon ketten...
...oder irgendwas...
...eigentlich hab ich da überhaupt keine Lust drauf...
...ja, aber du hast...
...du hast doch schon...
...das eingegrenzt, oder? Du weißt...
...du weißt schon, welches Plugin das macht, oder?
...die exklusive Shisha-Bar im Raum Wiesbaden...
...ja, das ist gar nicht so weit weg von mir...
...eh...
...ähm...
...aber die Seite geht bei mir echt schnell...
...ich hab da keine...keine...
...ja, also ich seh...ich seh's jetzt hier...
...der versucht, ähm...
...der versucht, Fonts nachzuladen...
...Fonts und, ähm...
...irgendwelche Bilder versucht er nachzuladen...
...JQuery-Themes...
...versucht er nachzuladen...
...aber ich sag mal so, das sind 1, 2, 3...
...4, 5, 6, 7, 8 Links...
...also bei mir ist die Seite wirklich sauschnell...
...ich drück da drauf und es ist da...
...also, äh...ich hab...
...also ich hab zumindest keine Verzögerung bei der Seite...
...jetzt...
...wir können uns das jetzt mal zusammen angucken...
...ich mach das jetzt mal auf dem...
...zweiten Rechner auf...
...oh...
...gucken wir uns mal hier an die Seite von dir...
...äh, nein...
...wartet mal...
...äh...
...irgendwie hab ich mein...
...hahaha...
...darf ich jetzt meine Maus wieder ver...
...HALLO? WINDOWS?
...come on, bruh...
...ich muss mir die Seite jetzt gerne angucken...
...aber ich hab keine Maus-Input mehr...
...Windows mag mich nicht mehr...
...ich hab nur noch Maus-Input in meiner VM...
...geil...
...was ist das denn?
...wartet mal...
...haha...
...da ist er wieder...
...Steuerung alt entfernen, beste...
...also...
...deine Seite ist das hier, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesehen hab...
...guck mal, die Seite ist bei mir...
...übel schnell...
...und ja, hier die 404s...
...wow...
...was ist das denn?
...krasses Diff...
...ach, das ist Image, Inline, Inline-Image...
...ok...
...also...
...also, ja, es...
...ist nicht...
...haha, eigentlich nicht...
...also, ist relativ schnell...
...zeig mal her...
...ähm...
...ich guck mir das jetzt grad mal ein bisschen an, ich hab echt kein...
...kein Nerv auf dieses Microsoft Zeug...
...gedöns da gerade...
...so, und hier sieht man doch jetzt irgendwo...
...kann man das irgendwie verstellen?
...nope...
...ich mein, der braucht, insgesamt braucht der schon...
...relativ...
...relativ lang...
...bis die Seite erscheint...
...also insgesamt braucht er 1,3 Sekunden...
...das ist aber für alles...
...und die Seite erscheint ja schon früher...
...ja...
...also, wie du das beheben kannst, seh ich jetzt eigentlich nur...
...ähm...
...ich weiß ja nicht, welches Plugin das ist, was das...
...was das nachlädt...
...aber ich mein, du müsstest halt...
...entweder müsstest du den Plugin-Typ kontaktieren...
...oder aber...
...du musst halt in den Source-Code gehen...
...also quasi in das HTML...
...die Seite aufmachen...
...und, äh, von dem Plugin...
...und halt die Sachen...
...da rausnehmen...
...ja gut, wenn das nicht vom Plugin kommt...
...wie kommt dann...
...wie kommt denn das Plugin überhaupt...
...die Idee, das hier zu laden...
...das Problem ist, dass Wordpress02 im fahrt...
...aha...
...hast du das vielleicht einfach kopiert?
...hast du das vielleicht in nem...
...mal in einem Wordpress02 liegen...
...gehabt und hast das Plugin dann...
...kopiert in ein anderes Wordpress?
...das ist immer sehr schwierig, so zu diagnostizieren...
...so in die...
...quasi in die Glaskugel gucken...
...so remote, aber...
...was machst du da eigentlich?
...jetzt guck ich mir grad die Webseite von nem Zuschauer an...
...die angeblich, äh, ultra langsam ist...
...also wenn du den...
...fahrt ohne Wordpress02 aufrufst, dann ist der Fahrt richtig...
...ja, nee, ich überleg mir nur grade...
...von wo das Wordpress02...
...herkommt, hast du das mal kopiert...
...oder umbenannt?
...hieß das vielleicht mal früher...
...Wordpress02, du hast es quasi...
...kopiert, also war das vielleicht mal...
...ganz am Anfang unter Wordpress02...
...und du hast den Ordner umbenannt...
...an sich ist immer alles...
...in Wordpress02...
...gewesen...
...ist alles Wordpress02...
...dann stell ich mir aber die Frage...
...warum man es nicht findet, ja...
...okay, es ist wirklich schwieriger als...
...remote...
...irgendwie was zu sagen...
...ich vermute ja mal...
...dass das Plugin entweder...
...vor einer anderen Wordpress-Installation...
...kommt, oder beziehungsweise...
...umkopiert...
...wurde, oder aber...
...dass man irgendwo halt einstellen kann, weil ich mein...
...das muss doch irgendwie auf die...
...auf die Idee kommen...
...den Kram hier...
...nachzuladen, so...
...und wenn du sagst, dass es...
...ohne Wordpress02...
...ja funktioniert...
...dann ist der Content ja prinzipiell da...
...aber entweder liegt WP-Content...
...unter Wordpress02...
...oder WP-Content liegt halt...
...unter...kann man doch mal gucken gerade...
...ja...
...WP-Content liegt ja hier drunter...
...ach so, ach der lädt...
...ah, tja...
...also...
...ja, das könnte natürlich ein Bug sein...
...ich frag mich halt, woran das her hat mit dem Wordpress02...
...was ist denn das für ein Plugin?
...ja, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich kenn mich da in dem Fall...
...leider zu wenig mit Wordpress aus, um da jetzt...
...irgendwas stichhaltig...
...diagnostizieren zu können...
...ja...
...ich mein, ich find die Seite ist...
...relativ schnell, ja das ist nicht schön, das stimmt...
...könntest du...ja, äh...
...Celora, das wollt ich auch grad sagen...
...könntest du nicht das Plugin mal wegschmeißen...
...und den Ordner löschen und nochmal neu installieren?
...Revolutionsbilder...
...heißt das Plugin, ok...
...wer weiß, was man da jetzt...
...findet, äh...
...bestimmt wieder wie die...
...der Typ, der mich letztens auf einer Pornseite...
...tubated hat, äh...
...Revolo...
...Wordpress...
...Plugin...
...Slider Revolution...
...Responsive Wordpress Slider...
...gucken jetzt mal auf denen ihre Seite, ob die das auch haben...
...hehehehe...
...nein, haben sie nicht...
...die wurden natürlich gelöscht, na klar hab ich die gelöscht...
...ach, kostet ja auch was...
...hallo...
...haben wir...
...ja, also, kann ich dir leider...
...detail nichts zu sagen, hab ich weder verwendet noch kenn ich...
...Wordpress großartig aus, also Bauchgefühl...
...sagt mir so eher, ähm...
...versucht das Plugin mal zu löschen...
...den Ordner zu...also komplett...
...komplett Plugin löschen...
...Ordner löschen und Plugin nochmal neu hinzufügen...
...oder aber vielleicht...
...hat einer im Chat noch irgendwie ne andere Idee...
...so, und jetzt hierzu meine...
...Formatierungsgedöns, ey, ich hab eigentlich...
...keinen Bock da jetzt...
...mit Microsoft Regex gesplittet...
...zu spielen...
...ich mein, guckt euch das mal an, das sieht doch echt aus wie hingeschätzt...
...oh Moment, er gibt nix mehr aus...
...warum gibt er nix mehr aus...
...was hab ich, was hab ich gelöscht...
...ah, für irgendwelche Gründen hab ich...
...gelöscht, dass er...
...ich mein...
...was war nochmal das Ziel...
...deiner aktuellen Query...
...äh...
...MSFT Partition...
...to Volume...
...also doch einfach Diskpart...
...ich krieg das schon hin, aber ich...
...hab da heut keinen Nerven mehr drauf...
...ich mein...
...es kann doch nicht sein, man muss doch...
...man muss doch irgendwie sagen können, hallo...
...komisches WMI...
...gib mal das Volume zu dieser...
...Partition so, irgendwie, was ordentliches...
...versteh ich nicht...
...es ist wirklich...
...massive eklig, ey...
...was halt auch nicht funktioniert...
...sind Access Paths...
...klappt auch nicht...
...können wir vielleicht...
...kann man sowas hier machen...
...ups, geh weg...
...was gerade gemacht wird, wir versuchen...
...automatisch...
...alle unformatierten...
...Platten an dem Rechner...
...zu initialisieren...
...zu partitionieren...
...zu formatieren und danach als...
...nächst gelegenen Laufwerksbuchstabe...
...zu mappen...
...und ich krieg hier meine Anfälle mit diesem...
...komischen WMI Windows Krempel, ey...
...scheint...
...kompliziert zu sein, ja...
...komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt hab...
...leider...
...geht das vielleicht...
...Moment...
...das muss es geben...
...Moment, das muss es geben...
...ah, das Access Path...
...ja, aber da steht nichts drinnen...
...ja, ich muss jetzt wirklich irgendwie dieses...
...komische...
...ich muss das wirklich hier irgendwie damit machen, ne...
...also ich muss hier irgendwie dieses...
...diese komische...
...MSFT Partition to Volume...
...ordentlich aufgerufen kriegen...
...du hast nicht zufällig eine Aufzeichnung...
...von was denn?
...ich...
...mir widerstrebt es innerlich...
...hier jetzt irgendwelche...
...er will den Porn...
...also eins sag ich euch...
...falls irgendwie einer davon eine Aufzeichnung hat...
...und das hier linkt, ist der Bun sicher...
...dann geht der Bun instant raus...
...ich hab das nicht umsonst gelöscht...
...und nicht umsonst die Clips gelöscht danach...
...ähm...
...nicht weil ich nicht will, dass es irgendwie einer...
...es kann meinetwegen einer sehen...
...das war ja im Prinzip auch nichts schlimmes...
...die Sache ist bloß, dass es komplett gegen die Twitch-Richtlinien ist...
...und deswegen will ich nicht, dass es das auf Twitch gibt...
...gegen die Aufzeichnung an sich...
...geht's mir gar nicht...
...das ist bloß komplett gegen Twitch-Richtlinien...
...ich mein, es war aus Versehen...
...ich dachte nicht, dass das...
...alt ne Porn-Seite ist...
...haha...
...ist auch ne 0,5 Sekunden irgendwie offen...
...aber es ist halt trotzdem gegen die Twitch-Richtlinien...
...und deswegen gibt's davon auch...
...hier keine Clips oder sonst was mehr...
...sollte irgendwie einer Clips posten...
...gibt's Instant Bun...
...ansonsten...
...wenn ihr's auf YouPorn hochladen wollt...
...kann er machen, ist mir wurscht...
...wobei ich mich bezweifle...
...dass da einer ne 0,5...
...Sekunden...
...Seite, andere Seite...
...interessiert...
...wenn dir irgendjemand das Tool abkaufen will...
...das Tool ist so spezifisch für euch...
...ich glaube nicht, dass das...
...weiß nicht, es könnte für andere auch nützlich sein...
...boah, dieses...
...Partitionierungs-Zeug, meine Güte...
...wie mir das auf den Keks geht hier...
...warum ist das hier so kompliziert?
...eigentlich müssen wir doch nur das hier wegschneiden, oder?
...seh ich das richtig?
...wir müssen aus Desktop...
...wir müssen aus dem Rechner...
...namen...
...müssen wir doch eigentlich nur...
...wenn wir kurz konzentrieren...
...konzentration...
...blitz...
...wow...
...was ist denn das?
...vorhin hat das doch schon geklappt...
...nein, das Formatieren hat noch nie funktioniert...
...ich muss jetzt...
...aus meiner Partition...
...ein Volume kriegen und das Volume kann ich...
...formatieren...
...ok, ähm...
...also eigentlich müssen wir doch nur...
...nur...
...das hier wegschneiden, oder?
...also wir müssen Partition Path...
...Äh, Partition Path...
...repla... ne, ähm...
...warum ist das eigentlich kein String?
...weils ein Management Path ist...
...ah, was gibt's denn da... oh, Moment...
...was gibt's denn da für Dinger?
...ist klar...
...Path...
...ist das vielleicht das Richtige?
...ist das vielleicht das Richtige...
...was wir brauchen?
...lul gratis Key...
...ein nicer gratis Key...
...ne, da ist auch...
...der Mist hier mit drinnen...
...ok...
...Äh, Partition Path...
...so, also, was soll das sein?
...replace?
...ne, warte mal, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
...ja, Moment, ich kann ja nicht...
...ich kann jetzt ja nicht replacen...
...ich muss doch regexen...
...ja, ich muss... ihr wisst ja...
...hast du ein Problem und willst es mit regex lösen...
...hast du zwei...
...re... ex...
...replace...
...ok...
...pattern...
...was machst du denn jetzt?
...ich versuche, alle Festplatten...
...in dem Rechner...
...zu initialisieren, also die, die noch leer sind...
...zu initialisieren...
...partitionieren, formatieren...
...und danach eine Laufwerksbuchstabe zu mappen...
...haha...
...krasser Shit...
...ähm...
...Chilorax, das ist geil...
...das ist der Wahnsinn, das ist echt nice...
...mal, guck dir das mal an...
...schau in den Stream gerade...
...mit meiner Freundin, wir verstehen jetzt keine Worte...
...und finden das lustig...
...wenn ihr es lustig findet, ist es ja auch gut...
...dann hat es wenigstens einen Zweck...
...aber macht euch nichts draus, ich verstehe es auch nicht...
...also vor allem nicht, warum Microsoft so...
...absolut unsäglichen...
...Kack da macht...
...ok...
...aber das muss ich sagen, Chilorax, das ist krass...
...how to match ABC...
...A plus B gleich C...
...regex...
...also sie versuchen...
...quasi...
...einen regex zu finden...
...für jeden Ausdruck...
...der so entsteht, also...
...eine Zahl plus die andere Zahl...
...ergibt C, also sowas wie...
...1, 2, 3...
...ja, oder...
...2, 2, 4...
...so sie versuchen einen regex zu finden, der das matcht...
...Alter...
...hohoho...
...ach du Scheiße...
...also, es ist nicht so, dass du...
...dannach...
...also, wenn du mit diesem regex was versuchst zu lösen...
...ist es ja nicht so, als hättest du danach 2 Probleme...
...danach bist du reif irgendwie für...
...für Ragequit...
...Allinster, Ragequit von der Brücke...
...runter...
...im Köpper, Kopf zuerst, ey...
...bist du reif danach, wenn du dir diesen regex angeguckt hast...
...gestörter Scheiß, ey...
...oh, VMware, geh weg...
...ok, also...
...regex, replace...
...meine Gehirnwindungen sind grad nicht in der...
...in...
...in der Lage...
...also, wir brauchen...
...beginn...
...beginnt mit...
...slash, slash...
...regex...
...regulärer Ausdruck, oder?
...regulärer Ausdruck?
...ja, wahrscheinlich regulärer Ausdruck, auf Deutsch...
...ok, gebe ich zu, sagt der Mix...
...damit kannst du...
...ich kenn die Definition nicht, aber du kannst...
...mit regex kannst du quasi Text matchen...
...anhand von...
...von Wildcards im Endeffekt...
...im Endeffekt, ja...
...also du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel...
...so mal ein ganz simpler regex, na...
...also mal angenommen du hast jetzt einen Text...
...so was wie...
...Hallo Twitch Chat...
...und du willst jetzt überprüfen...
...dass...
...dieser Text auch wirklich...
...ähm...
...mit Hallo anfängt...
...wolltest du diesen regex nehmen, sagst du hier...
...regex Start...
...starterzeile, gefolgt von Hallo...
...ähm, wenn du jetzt willst...
...dass das quasi immer...
...drei Wörter, oder sag mal so, dass das...
...dass es, keine Ahnung, dass es...
...Buchstaben sind...
...ähm...
...beliebig viele...
...Buchstaben hintereinander...
...gefolgt von...
...warte mal, war W überhaupt Buchstaben?
...nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle...
...ja doch, Wordcharacter ist W, ne...
...ähm...
...danach ein Leerzeichen...
...danach muss ein Wort kommen, was mit...
...T anfängt...
...und, ähm, irgendwie...
...beliebig weiter geht...
...bis zum Schluss...
...irgendwie sowas in der Richtung...
...also du kannst quasi mit regex Texte beschreiben...
...und danach gucken, ob diese Texte darauf matchen...
...also du checkst quasi...
...eher so die Syntax von dem Text...
...also quasi den Aufbau von dem Text...
...anstatt halt den...
...du weißt ja den Text oftmals...
...den Text noch gar nicht...
...wofür man das braucht...
...ja, das naheliegendste ist, um Input zu überprüfen...
...also jetzt mal als Beispiel in regex...
...was man, wo jeder schreit...
...weil man ihn dafür nicht nimmt...
...aber als Beispiel ist er trotzdem ganz gut...
...also wenn du jetzt hier sowas hast wie...
...maxatgooglemail.com...
...atgooglemail.com...
...man, man, gleich gesagt...
...man verwendet keine regexe zum E-Mail überprüfen...
...da könntest du sagen, ok...
...ich will jetzt gucken, ob...
...in dem, was der User...
...eingegeben hat...
...ob da eine E-Mail Adresse drinsteht...
...so dann würdest du eine regex machen...
...wie gesagt, für Mailadressen und für HTML...
...kein regex verwenden, aber nur mal als Beispiel...
...sagst du, ok, das ganze geht los...
...danach darf...
...dürfen nur Buchstaben A bis Z kommen...
...danach muss ein Add sein...
...danach darf wieder nur bis A bis Z kommen...
...und...
...also darfst du halt auch...
...zahlen in der Mail...
...aber jetzt nur mal als Beispiel...
...klein A bis Z Add...
...da kannst du sagen, ok...
...danach ist gefolgt von einem Punkt...
...und jetzt lass ich...
...Domänen zu irgendwie...
...com.de und net...
...so, und darauf...
...könntest du jetzt quasi diesen Text hier überprüfen...
...da kannst du sagen, ok...
...ich erwarte...
...dass meine User E-Mail Adressen haben...
...die nach folgendem Muster aufgebaut sind...
...also quasi nur Kleinbuchstaben...
...Add...
...beginn...
...nur Kleinbuchstaben...
...beliebig oft hintereinander...
...danach kommt irgendwann ein Add...
...dann kommen wieder nur Kleinbuchstaben...
...beliebig oft hintereinander...
...danach muss ein Punkt kommen...
...und danach kommt entweder...
...com.de oder net...
...und dann ist fertig...
...kann ich das einfach nutzen...
...um nur Zahlen als Input...
...zu akzeptieren, ja genau...
...wenn der User was anderes eingibt...
...ja dann matcht der regex nicht...
...und wenn der regex nicht matcht...
...kannst du sagen...
...sagst du Input ist dein Text...
...also sagen wir mal hier...
...der User hat eingegeben...
...so und du willst jetzt matchen...
...ob dein...
...dein Input eine Zahl ist...
...dann machst du einfach sowas hier...
...das bedeutet...
...in regex Logik...
...also Hütchen hier...
...ist immer der Anfang...
...von der Zeile und Dollar...
...ist immer der Ende von der Zeile...
...dann sagst du nur Digits...
...und das mache ich oft...
...so viele Digits wie du willst...
...von Anfang bis Ende...
...das ist der regex dafür...
...und danach weißt du ob...
...nur Zahlen matchen...
...eine andere Schreibweise dafür...
...wäre auch so...
...das kannst du damit machen...
...aber das ist richtig was der Chad schreibt...
...das geht auch einfacher...
...also du brauchst keine großartige regex...
...um einen Text zu überprüfen...
...ob es eine Zahl ist...
...und da kommt ein bool raus...
...da kannst du sagen...
...in dem Fall...
...if...ich glaube es kommt nicht direkt ein bool raus...
...wenn du...
...genau entweder sagst du hier...
...ist match...
...dann kommt ein bool raus...
...oder du kannst sagen match...
...und dann kannst du quasi gucken wie viel gematcht hat...
...und kannst einfach sagen success...
...success wäre dann im Endeffekt auch das gleiche...
...wie ist match...
...wobei die schönere Variante...
...wenn du wissen willst ob es matcht...
...wäre sowas hier...
...dann sagst du regex ist match...
...und dann machst du halt...
...wenn es matcht machst du hier was...
...und wenn es nicht matcht...
...machst du halt im else was...
...das kannst du damit machen...
...aber sag mal so...
...wenn du einen Text auf Zahlen...
...überprüfen willst...
...gibt es ja noch andere Varianten...
...die erste Variante zum Beispiel...
...die simpelste Variante...
...wenn dein Fehler...
...unanfällig ist...
...ist das du hier sowas machst...
...try parse...
...du sagst du nimmst einfach...
...sagen wir mal so wenn du Zahlen ab 0 haben willst...
...zahlen haben willst...
...kannst du auch sowas sagen...
...versuch mir mal diesen Text...
...als...
...int zu parsen...
...kannst du auch machen...
...wobei das nicht so schön ist...
...weil man könnte immer noch sowas eingeben...
...wenn man sowas parsen würde...
...ich denke mal wenn du sowas eingibst...
...wird das geparst werden und du willst ja als Input...
...nicht einfach eine Zahl sondern...
...also sieht man schon dass das in dem Fall ein bisschen fehleranfällig sein könnte...
...du möchtest ja gar nicht dass einer hier...
...ein anderes Zeichen als Zahlen eingeben kann...
...sagen wir mal so...
...minus 181276...
...ist zwar eine Zahl...
...und lässt sich als Zahl parsen...
...allerdings du hast ja definiert als Text Input...
...dürfen es nur Zahlen sein...
...also ist ein Minus...
...eigentlich nicht erlaubt und...
...würde allerdings hier durchrutschen...
...das heißt das ist dann schon ein bisschen fehleranfälliger...
...ich meine du kannst...
...natürlich auch...
...wie gesagt du brauchst keinen regex...
...du kannst hier natürlich auch diesen String hier nehmen...
...und quasi eine Schleife drüber laufen lassen...
...und gucken...
...ob jedes Zeichen eine Zahl ist...
...das ist mit Sicherheit deutlich schneller...
...als zu regexen an der Stelle...
...wenn es auf Performance ankommt...
...haha...
...genau Törafox...
...wir trainieren erstmal unsere...
...AI drauf...
...wir basteln irgendwas mit TensorFlow...
...oder so zusammen was uns Zahlen erkennt...
...richtig...
...heutzutage macht man ja alles mit AI...
...ich habe letztens in einem Microsoft Vortrag gelesen...
...leute ich laber jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde...
...dann gehe ich pennen...
...ich habe keinen Bock auf dieses Microsoft Kram...
...aber ich habe letztens bei Microsoft gesehen...
...einen Vortrag zur neuen Visual Studio Version...
...war das glaube ich...
...und da haben sie gesagt...
...sie haben jetzt hier...
...quasi was eingebaut...
...in der Visual Studio Version kommt ein Feature...
...das wenn man beispielsweise...
...die Autocompletion aufmacht...
...wir sind ja in der Microsoft Welt...
...wo man Intellisense aufmacht...
...warte mal...
...Slaver...
...das erzähle ich dir gleich...
...was zu noch...
...wenn man jetzt hier die Intellisense aufmacht...
...die Autocompletion...
...haben sie in der nächsten Visual Studio Version...
...quasi was drin...
...wo es nicht mehr alphabetisch ist...
...sondern...
...die meist benutzten Methoden...
...oben stehen...
...und da haben sie gesagt...
...so nach dem Motto...
...das haben wir Deep Learning...
...und Analysiert und AI...
...und Künstliche Intelligenz und Big Data...
...und hat bloß noch Blockchain gefehlt...
...und alles super kompliziert...
...und wir haben da so tolle Technik...
...und...
...im Endeffekt haben sie gesagt...
...sie haben die 100 größten...
...C-Sharp Github Projekte...
...durch Crapped...
...und die meisten Funktionsaufrufe...
...sich rausgesucht...
...wozu man dafür krasses Machine Learning...
...AI und sonst was braucht...
...keine Ahnung...
...aber angeblich machen sie das damit...
...das ging schon vor 30 Jahren...
...aber Microsoft...
...braucht das...
...braucht da Machine Learning dazu...
...um zu gucken...
...was in 100 Projekten am meisten für Funktionen aufgerufen werden...
...warum auch immer...
...das sind die gleichen...
...die sich diesen Kack hier ausgedacht haben...
...aber ich glaube sie haben das einfach nur erzählt...
...weil es gut klingt...
...ich glaube das haben die einfach nur erzählt...
...die haben aber tatsächlich...
...ist der Stream abgekackt?
...also der Musik-Stream...
...oh der Musik-Stream ist abgekackt...
...leise...
...irgendwie ist der Musik-Stream abgekackt...
...ja...
...in der nächsten Version haben sie noch ein paar andere Sachen drin...
...ähm...
...was war das denn was sie erzählt haben...
...also...
...auch sowas hier wie dass sie die Sachen...
...dass sie die Sachen analysiert haben...
...von den größten Github Projekten...
...und...
...sie hatten...was war das denn...
...sie hatten noch irgendwas ganz cooles drin...
...wo ich gesagt habe das ist wirklich ganz nett...
...ja genau...
...und diese Funktion ist auch unterschiedlich...
...je nach...
...Objekt-Typ...
...also zum Beispiel...
...wenn man jetzt hier String verwendet...
...dann steht da...sagen wir mal...
...die meist verwendete Funktion wäre...
...keine Ahnung...wäre...wäre mal angenommen...
...ja wäre jetzt Equals...was nicht so ist...
...aber nur mal so theoretisch...
...mal angenommen das wäre bei String...
...bei den meist versuchten...bei den meist...
...verwendeten Funktionen oben...
...allerdings gibt es ja Equals auch für Object...
...und...
...die haben das quasi...die haben noch irgendwie...
...die Vererbungs-Hierarchie mit reingebastelt...
...also sprich...es könnte sein...dass...
...wenn es an mehreren Klassen die gleiche...
...Methode gibt...dass das halt...
...je nach Klasse unterschiedlich gewichtet ist...
...es war ganz cool was sie gezeigt haben...
...wozu man da jetzt so...so...
...tief vergreifendes Machine Learning...
...verwendet...keine Ahnung...
...Äh...Max welche Tastatur verwendest du...die...die hier...
...nein...nein...nein...nicht...nicht...
...DDR4...ich verwende kein DDR4...
...in der Tastatur...die hier...
...ja...ähm...
...so und jetzt...
...was zum...
...Slaver...
...der Ivor...
...ich...mit Leadspeak-Namen tue ich mir...
...irgendwie...schwer...
...also was für ein nicht mehr richtiges Leadspeak ist...
...das sind einfach die vier...die Ahn...zu Vieren...
...und die Ehen zu Dreien...das ist ja nur...
...halbherziges Leadspeak...das geht schon...
...noch besser...kann zum Beispiel auch das...
...S noch einen Dollar draus machen...aus dem L noch eine Eins...
...dann wird das alles noch ein bisschen...
...verleadspeakter...
...ok...also er hat gefragt...
...wir...wir machen jetzt einfach noch so ein bisschen...
...so ein bisschen...Beginner-Zeugs...noch mal...
...eine Viertelstunde...also...
...er fragt...
...wie verhindere ich das die Konsole abschmiert...
...wenn der User bei int was anderes eingibt...
...ja...also du meinst...
...so was hier in der Richtung...also dieses...
...so dieses übliche was man macht...wenn man anfängt...
...so...bitte geben sie eine Zahl ein...
...ja...also...
...du sagst jetzt hier quasi...Konsole...
...Konsole Read...
...so Konsole Read Key...
...oder sowas...ne...
...ääh...Result...
...
...Result Key...
...oder...Char...kannst du sagen...
...so...und dann hast du...
...den Key hier drinne...und...
...du hast dem User ja gesagt...
...er soll eine Zahl eingeben...
...wahrscheinlich...weil du danach...
...versuchst was mit Zahlen zu machen...
...zum Beispiel sowas wie...
...Result...Plus...
...1...
...nachdem das nicht geht...
...hast du halt...wir casten das ganze vielleicht noch zu int...
...oder sowas in der Richtung...so...
...und das kackt...das kackt den dann ab...
...und was du dann machen musst ist...
...du musst das erstmal parsen als int...
...äh...das geht ja...
...was hat der für Schmerzen...
...achso...äh...
...Moment...ahja...
...Moment...geht das nicht...
...wie...
...muss man das wirklich so machen...geht das nicht anders...
...ok vielleicht geht...
...zumindest...du musst sowas parsen...
...äähm...
...erstmal das als int...so...und hier hast du jetzt das Problem...
...wenn...
...der User jetzt sagen wir mal hier den...
...gibt an der Stelle...dann kackts ab...
...weil...das sagt es ja hier auch...
...ähm...int parse...
...konvertiert Zeichenfolgen...blablabla...eine...
...entsprechende...äh...konvertiert...
...einen Text zum int...allerdings...
...und das steht ja da unten...wirft...
...argument null exception...format exception...
...overflow exception...das bedeutet...
...wenn ich da jetzt irgendwas reinschiebe...
...was man nicht parsen kann zu einer Zahl...
...ähm...
...da gehts kaputt...
...dafür kannst du das hier verwenden...
...und zwar try parse...
...mit try parse...
...sachst du hier...
...konvertiere...warum gibts das...
...eigentlich nicht für character...
...kann ich ja nicht irgendwie nen String oder so rausholen...
...ist schon eklig irgendwie oder...
...ne kann ich nicht...
...ja und wenn du try parse verwendest...
...dann kannst du zum Beispiel sagen...
...so...
...und dann sagst du hier irgendwie...
...aut int...
...value oder sowas...
...so und jetzt kackt die Konsole nicht mehr ab...
...weil jetzt sagst du ihm nicht...
...ja parse mir den Input...
...als Zahl...
...und du musst das machen egal was passiert...
...sonst muss es kaputt gehen...
...du sagst ihm jetzt versuche mal...
...den Input als...
...Zahl zu parsen...
...wenn das funktioniert...
...dann schreibt das Ergebnis in value rein...
...wenn es nicht funktioniert...
...ja dann ist mein return-Wert false...
...also...
...könnst du quasi sagen...
...neue C-Sharp Syntax...
...so...
...hier drinnen könntest du jetzt sagen...
...value plus 1...
...das ist vollkommen safe...
...und wird die Konsole bei einem User Input...
...der keine Zahl eingeben...
...nie wieder crashen lassen...
...so weit so gut...
...ja du sagst ihm jetzt ja hier...
...versuche das mal zu parsen...
...und wenn das halt nicht funktioniert...
...dann wird das if hier einfach nicht ausgeführt...
...also halt der Block im...
...der Body vom if wird nicht ausgeführt...
...du könntest natürlich auch noch so ein else machen...
...und dann irgendwie sowas sagen wie hier...
...bast...
...keine Ahnung...
...ich weiß nicht...sagst du halt irgendwas...
...hafti...
...abi...beste...sagst du dann...
...als Antwort...schreibt man das überhaupt so...
...abi...
...kein Plan was mit dem toString ist...
...ja wie kein Plan...also...
...toString ist also ziemlich das...
...basicste vom basicsten in C-Sharp...
...also wenn euch das euer Lehrer nicht gezeigt hat...
...dann weiß ich auch noch...
...toString brauchst in C-Sharp fast an jeder Ecke...
...ne toString konvertiert gar nichts...
...das ist auch...
...das ist auch was was...
...glaub ich viele Leute...
...verwirrt am Anfang...
...man...man...
...denkt ja irgendwie...
...so im Kopf dass...
...wenn man hier irgendwie ein Objekt hat...
...und sagt toString...
...dass dann...
...irgendwie eine logische...
...ja dass das Objekt dann irgendwie...
...in eine logische Zeichenfolge...
...also irgendwie in eine Zeichenfolge die logisch ist...
...oder sinnvoll ist für das Objekt konvertiert wird...
...das muss...
...aber nicht so sein...
...dass toString in dem Fall...
...funktioniert...
...liegt eigentlich einzig und allein daran...
...weil Microsoft...
...kann uns das jetzt nochmal angucken...
...ok ich erzähl scheiße und man sieht es...
...achso Konsolen-Key-Info...
...wir wollen nicht Konsolen-Key-Info...
...wir wollen...
...äh...
...kann man nicht sagen Key-Character...
...Definition einsehen...
...ich will eigentlich...
...die Definition von Character einsehen...
...ja...
...kann man nicht sagen...
...Character-G zur Definition...
...so und da sieht man...
...als irgendwo drinnen...
...ok das war jetzt keine gute Idee...
...toString...
...ja und da sieht man...
...die haben das überschrieben...
...das toString...
...also sprich toString gibt standardmäßig...
...ein absolut sinnloses Result...
...toString gibt standardmäßig...
...den Type Name...
...aus...
...also sprich wenn du ne Klasse hast...
...die ähm...
...keine Ahnung du hast ne Klasse...
...du hast ne Klasse für Lehrer...
...ja...
...du hast ne Klasse die heißt Lehrer...
...und du erwartest jetzt eigentlich wenn du sagst...
...keine Ahnung...
...new Lehrer und dann den Namen vom Lehrer...
...und dann sagst du Lehrer toString...
...dann würdest du ja eigentlich logischerweise erwarten...
...ok da kommt jetzt das Output Vorname Nachname oder sowas...
...aber...
...ist ja gar nicht was du für ne sinnvolle Ausgabe hältst...
...das heißt die Default Implementierung...
...für toString ist komplett Useless...
...und gibt einfach nur den Namen der Klasse...
...aus...
...das heißt sobald du willst das toString...
...was ordentliches macht...
...musst du toString in deiner Klasse überschreiben...
...sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht...
...glücklicherweise hat das Microsoft für die meisten Sachen...
...wo es sinnvoll ist schon gemacht...
...also dass das Character toString...
...nen String zurückgibt...
...der eben...
...das jeweilige Zeichen beinhaltet...
...und nicht den Klassennamen...
...Char...
...legt einzig und allein daran...
...weil Microsoft das überschrieben hat...
...mein Lehrer mag else-if nicht...
...dann hat dein Lehrer wahrscheinlich noch nie was länger als...
...ein paar Zeilen selbst programmiert...
...if...
...else-if...
...und else ist eigentlich...
...da gibt es nichts was man nicht mögen kann...
...warum mag er das denn nicht...
...er gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn...
...das ist so wie wenn ich sage...
...ähm...
...keine Ahnung...
...vorschleifen mag ich nicht oder...
...das ist einfach essentielles...
...Kontrollkonstrukt was jede...
...Programmiersprache braucht...
...ja else-if kann manchmal...
...ein bisschen heimtückisch sein...
...ähm...
...zum Beispiel...
...mal gucken ob mir das ein gescheites Beispiel einfällt...
...also else-if kann ein bisschen...
...heimtückisch sein...
...wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt hier oben irgendwie...
...überprüfe 1 gleich 2...
...wir stellen uns mal vor...
...das sind Variablen...
...so...
...und das stimmt nicht...
...und hier unten...
...überprüfe ich keine Ahnung...
...1 gleich 3 oder so...
...das ist jetzt bescheuert...
...und wenn ich hier oben das...
...überprüft habe und das nicht...
...zutrifft...
...dann kann es ja sein...
...dass ich hier unten...
...also hier unten weiß ich ja nicht...
...dass es da oben nichts...
...ich komme hier nur rein...
...dass es da oben nicht gematcht hat...
...aber ich weiß den Zustand nicht...
...ich weiß nur es hat nicht funktioniert...
...das ist alles...
...aber es könnte jetzt ja sein...
...dass ich quasi...
...dass das richtige gemacht wird...
...hier nochmal checken müsste...
...dass das zum Beispiel...
...dass das 1 gleich 2 ist...
...ich gebe zu das ist jetzt ein ziemliches scheiß Beispiel...
...weil in dem Fall ist es relativ einfach zu sehen...
...ähm...
...aber wenn du ein langes if hast mit vielen else-en zwischendurch...
...dann kann es durchaus mal sein...
...dass du quasi ein else-if nur ausführen...
...willst...
...wenn irgendwas oben drüber in einer ganz speziellen...
...kombination...
...nicht funktioniert hat...
...das heißt else-if ist manchmal...
...ein bisschen heimtückig dass man...
...aus versehen Sachen ausgeführt kriegt...
...die man nicht ausgeführt kriegen will...
...ähm...
...aber ansonsten wenn es sinnvoll ist...
...also man kann nicht sagen else-if mag ich nicht...
...also else-if das ist an manchen...
...stellen schlicht und ergreifend notwendig...
...ich denke was...
...andere Frage...
...switch case oder if...
...das kommt ein bisschen drauf an...
...also in der Regel...
...bei einfachen Sachen...
...also in der Regel ein if...
...ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich im Chat...
...nicht dass ich zu weit oben bin...
...if schleifen ja best...
...es gibt viele die sagen das...
...ja...
...also...
...wofür man ein interface benötigt...
...das ist interessant...
...nochmal zu dem...
...also jetzt erst nochmal zu dieser...
...gesagten Sache mit switch...
...also normalerweise...
...verwendet man ein if...
...aber es gibt Sachen...
...da ist es sinnvoll ein switch case zu verwenden...
...zum Beispiel...
...du hast...
...was nehmen wir mal für ein Beispiel...
...ja...
...zum Beispiel du hast ein web client...
...kann man den importieren...
...so du hast ein web client...
...request...
...wir führen das jetzt nicht wirklich aus...
...client...
...download...
...file bla bla...
...bla...
...result...
...response...
...äh...
...da geht das jetzt nicht...
...was hat der für schmerzen...
...achso...
...darf man nicht...
...darf man das hier gar nicht zeigen...
...äh...
...ah...
...ok...
...ich weiß gerade aus dem Kopf nicht wie man das ordentlich macht...
...also...
...man muss sich doch hier irgendwie...
...man muss sich doch irgendwie die response anzeigen lassen...
...können...
...kann man sich die response nicht anzeigen lassen...
...naja zum Beispiel wenn du...
...einen request machst und du erwartest...
...dass der server mit...
...10 verschiedenen Fehler Codes...
...antworten kann...
...ja also zum Beispiel du hast jetzt hier...
...kann jetzt sein das sind Server...
...hier was weiß ich...
...error code oder sowas...
...da hast du hier error was weiß ich...
...äh...
...omegalull...
...poggers...
...pogchamp...
...so...
...und wenn du das jetzt checken willst...
...ob es eines davon zutrifft...
...kann ich das jetzt überhaupt so machen...
...ja...
...da ist es aber schon...
...dafür ist ein switch case ganz ganz nützlich...
...das ist nämlich schöner in dem Fall...
...als ein if...
...da bist du dir insofern...
...auch sicher dass du jeden Fall behandelt hast...
...das ist dann ganz cool...
...da kannst du jetzt hier sagen okay...
...wenn das und das der Fall ist dann mach ich das...
...wenn das und das der Fall ist mach ich das...
...der Unterschied war früher...
...dass du quasi ein if...
...in einem if kannst du dynamische Sachen machen...
...also in einem if kannst du ohne Probleme sagen...
...wenn e gleich das ist...
...und 1...
...gleich gleich 1 dann mache das...
...das ging in einem switch case...
...wenn nichts davon der Fall ist...
...dann wird default genommen...
...das kannst du in einem switch nicht machen...
...mittlerweile geht es...
...ja ich sag nur das ging früher die ganze Zeit nicht...
...ähm...
...du konntest in einem if quasi...
...immer nur so ein...
...ding checken...
...mittlerweile geht das...
...auch anders...
...mittlerweile kann man hier drinnen...
...hier drinnen auch sagen...
...hier irgendwie ähm...
...ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das funktioniert hat...
...ist...
...äh...
...irgendwie sowas...
...äh ich krieg jetzt grad die...
...mittlerweile kann man auch...
...ich kriegs aus dem Kopf...
...grad nicht hin aber man kann mittlerweile auch...
...in cases kann man auch irgendwie...
...logik rein basteln...
...dann muss ich hier oben wahrscheinlich...
...was anderes reinschreiben...
...wenn da eigentlich äh...
...switch case halt wenn ich irgendwelche...
...return werte überprüfen muss oder...
...irgendwelche ähm...
...irgendwelche e-namen geschichten oder...
...irgendwelche response codes oder sowas...
...in der regel hast du ja eigentlich...
...ich sag mal so wenn du eine Abfrage hast...
...die einen if, einen else if oder einen else hat...
...dann ist das meistens schon relativ viel...
...größteile der Fälle hast du eigentlich...
...einzelne ifs...
...gefolgt von einem if else...
...manchmal auch einen if mit nur einem else if...
...aber...
...sagen wir mal so mehr als...
...einen if mit mehr als drei Blöcken hast du eigentlich...
...relativ selten...
...Engine X oder Apache Engine X...
...so jetzt war noch die Frage...
...wofür benötigt man...
...ein Interface...
...ja das ist ein bisschen...
...ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären und...
...sagen wir mal so die Grenzen zwischen...
...Klasse vor allem abstrakter Klasse...
...und Interface...
...verschwemmen so ein bisschen...
...und vor allem auch...
...in zukünftigen C-Sharp Versionen...
...aktuell ist es so...
...das ist aber schon angekündigt...
...dass sich das ändern wird in einer nächsten Version...
...aktuell ist es ja so ein Interface...
...gibt einfach nur an...
...was...
...implementiert werden muss...
...also sprich wenn ich jetzt hier ein Interface habe...
...iTwitchChat...
...dann möchte ich quasi jede Klasse...
...die iTwitchChat implementiert...
...erfordere ich...
...dass die eine Methode hat...
...sendMessage...
...und eine Methode hat...
...getMessage...
...mehr kann ich...
...bei Interfaces nicht angeben...
...das bedeutet...
...wenn ich jetzt eine Klasse habe...
...die iTwitchChat...
...implementiert...
...dann muss die und das ist aber auch das einzige...
...was sie muss in irgendeiner...
...Art und Weise diese beiden Methoden implementieren...
...das hat den Vorteil...
...dass ich mich nicht drum...
...kümmern muss...
...was genau meine Klasse ist...
...dass...
...wenn jetzt was...
...wenn du das komplette Projekt selbst machst...
...und wenn du...
...wenn es klein und übersichtlich ist...
...dann wirst du wahrscheinlich keine Interfaces brauchen...
...aber spätestens wenn es darum geht...
...dass du irgendwelche Tests baust...
...oder wenn du dir die Möglichkeit...
...offen lassen willst...
...dass du irgendwie mal...
...was austauschen kannst...
...dann wirst du wahrscheinlich ein Interface...
...eine abstrakte Klasse brauchen...
...ein großer Unterschied zwischen einem Interface und einer abstrakten Klasse ist...
...ein Interface gibt einfach nur vor...
...was implementiert werden muss...
...eine abstrakte Klasse...
...kann selber...
...Implementierung mitliefern...
...also du kannst hier in einem Interface...
...ist es verboten hier irgendwie Code reinzuschreiben...
...das geht schlicht und ergreifend nicht...
...wohlgemerkt das ändert sich...
...ich glaube in der nächsten C-Sharp Version...
...in der nächsten C-Sharp Version...
...kannst du Default Implementierung...
...im Interface mitliefern...
...wobei dann...
...der Unterschied zwischen...
...abstrakten Klassen und Interfaces...
...die sind ja noch da...
...aber die sind dann schon wirklich im Detail eher zu suchen...
...ein Beispiel...
...wo du zum Beispiel ein Interface gut verwenden kannst...
...ist wenn du...
...sagen wir mal du hast eine Anwendung die eine Datenbank verwendet...
...das ist glaube ich so...
...das ist ein ganz passendes Beispiel...
...wenn du eine...
...Anwendung hast die eine Datenbank braucht...
...damit du irgendwie die Schüler in der Klasse reinschreiben kannst...
...so...
...und du hast jetzt gesagt ey...
...für eine Klasse mit...
...sagen wir mal 25 Leuten...
...dann nehmen wir eine SQLite Datenbank...
...da brauchen wir nichts großartiges...
...das speichern wir mit der Anwendung SQLite gut ist...
...wenn du das jetzt so programmierst...
...dass du quasi direkt...
...die SQLite Library verwendest...
...welche auch immer das dann ist...
...um deine Sachen in die Datenbank zu schreiben...
...dann hast du das Problem...
...wenn du irgendwann beispielsweise sagst...
...ha ich möchte jetzt aber die ganze Schule erfassen...
...oder ich möchte jetzt landesweit...
...alle Schulen erfassen und sagst okay...
...da ist eine SQLite Datenbank...
...nicht mehr sinnvoll...
...oder zum Beispiel du möchtest...
...mit mehreren Usern darauf zugreifen...
...spätestens dann ist eine SQLite Datenbank nicht mehr sinnvoll...
...das heißt da müsstest du komplett...
...deine komplette...
...Logik umstricken auf sagen wir jetzt...
...Postgres oder auf MySQL...
...oder auf ja Gott hilf uns...
...MSSQL...
...wenn du beispielsweise aber...
...deine...
...Datenzugriffsgeschichten...
...über einen Interface...
...machst...
...dann kannst du darunter die Implementierung...
...austauschen...
...soweit die reine Lehre...
...die Implementierung austauschen...
...von SQLite auf Postgres...
...und du musst eigentlich...
...in der Logik drüber nichts ändern...
...weil du ja nie direkt auf den Postgres...
...auf den SQLite...
...Library gedönst zugreifst...
...sondern immer nur...
...auf die SQLite Klassen...
...interface...
...hat man das jetzt verstanden?
...ich habe einen Visualisierer in Java programmiert...
...nur langsam wird es mit der Performance...
...eng...
...und ich glaube dass es in OpenGL mit C Sharp...
...nochmal besser aussehen würde...
...allerdings kann ich wirklich gar kein C Sharp...
...was wäre deine Einschätzung wie schwer...
...der Umstieg von C Sharp auf C Sharp von Java ist?
...gar nicht...
...es besteht bloß die Gefahr dass wenn du von Java...
...auf C Sharp umsteigst...
...dass du nicht mehr zu Java zurück willst...
...das kann dir schon passieren...
...für OpenGL gibt es übrigens eine schöne Library...
...für C Sharp...
...das da...
...obei ich mir überlegen würde...
...ins ernsthaft wenn es...
...Windows Only sein soll...
...ob du es nicht mit DirectX machst...
...weil OpenGL...
...Treibergeschichten unter Windows...
...ist immer so ein Ding für sich...
...geht aber...
...aber wenn du Windows Only machst...
...will ich mir überlegen ob ich es nicht mit DirectX mache...
...aber der Umstieg von Java auf C Sharp...
...ist nicht so ein Ding...
...spielst du eigentlich noch Overwatch?
...ich habe es gerade erst gesehen...
...wer die Message geschrieben hat...
...Witchy spielst du noch Overwatch?
...ich habe ja mittlerweile keinen Nerv mehr drauf...
...Flo96 sagt...
...interface ist nur eine freiwillige Einschränkung in der Klasse...
...in der das Interface implementiert wird...
...ne du...
...ja oder ich weiß nicht wie du das genau meinst...
...also...
...du kannst in der Klasse alles machen was du willst...
...du kannst auch...
...ich habe mich ganz vergessen...
...ich habe den allergrößten Unterschied...
...zwischen Klassen und Interfaces...
...in C Sharp vergessen...
...den mit Abstand größten...
...der sich wahrscheinlich auch nie ändern wird...
...z.B. du hast hier eine Klasse...
...iClass...
...du hast ein Interface...
...iInterface...
...und du hast noch eine Abstract...
...Class...
...BaseClass...
...so...
...jetzt kommt es...
...wenn man...
...damit rumhantiert...
...also...
...ich kann in C Sharp...
...nur von einer Klasse was erben...
...ich kann aber...
...von beliebig vielen...
...Interfaces erben...
...was heißt erben...
...ist ja gar nicht erben in dem Sinn...
...das habe ich vergessen...
...also du kannst...
...nur von einer Klasse erben...
...du kannst aber beliebig viele...
...Interfaces implementieren...
...das heißt du kannst eine Klasse haben...
...die 5 verschiedene Interfaces implementiert...
...und an der Stelle...
...wo du sie verwendest...
...castest du sie einfach auf das richtige Interface...
...und schon...
...bist du unabhängig von der Klasse...
...das ist nämlich auch ein schönes Beispiel...
...du könntest jetzt einfach sagen...
...ich fange jetzt mal mit einer Klasse an...
...für spezielle Sachen...
...und danach machst du 5 draus...
...dann hast du halt 5 Klassen...
...die dann jeweils eine Klasse Interface...
...eine Klasse Interface 2 implementieren...
...aber du musst dich nie um die eigentliche...
...Implementierung dann kümmern...
...oder geschweige denn überhaupt wissen...
...dass es MyClass1 oder so...
...gibt...
...Nevus, Trium...
...genau gut das du sagst...
...gut das du nochmal nachgefragt hast...
...das hatte ich ganz vergessen...
...das ist der große Unterschied zwischen Klassen und Interfaces...
...bei Klassen spricht man von vererben...
...also sprich...
...myClass erbt...
...von BaseClass...
...interfaces werden quasi immer implementiert...
...wenn man...
...bei der fachmännisch...
...korrekten Bezeichnung dafür...
...ja...
...also man hört quasi ganz oft so...
...inherit BaseClass und...
...implement Interface...
...woran arbeitest du...
...gerade machen wir...
...Einsteigerfragen...
...vorher hab ich...
...versucht noch in mein...
...in das Tool für Hardwarerad einzubauen...
...dass wir...
...unbenutzte Festplatten formatieren können...
...und Laufwerksbuchstaben mappen...
...aber hab ich keinen Bock mehr gehabt...
...weiterzumachen heute...
...weil Microsoft...
...eklig ist...
...ja genau Flo96...
...das Interface sagt einfach nur...
...du musst...
...spezielle Methoden in deiner Klasse haben...
...was anderes sagt das nicht...
...die Klasse kann sonst noch...
...alles mögliche andere machen...
...ja also du könntest ne klasse Klospülung haben...
...solange die Eiwaschbecken implementiert...
...kannst du sie als Waschbecken verwenden...
...vollkommen egal...
...ob das ne Klospülung ist...
...die kann alles machen...
...solange sie das Interface implementiert...
...und wenn das Interface Eiwaschbecken...
...quasi ein Property Wasserhahn hat...
...dann muss halt...
...die Klasse Klospülung irgendwie gucken...
...wie sie Wasserhahn implementiert...
...wenn sie das hinkriegt...
...kannst du sie als Ei...
...als Eiwaschbecken verwenden...
...da gibt es ja mittlerweile Klos...
...so ne...
...so ne Düse dran...
...da kann das schon sein...
...also Ritchie ich würde dir empfehlen...
...wenn du jetzt mit C-Sharp anfängst...
...für was für ne Plattform...
...entwickelst du eigentlich...
...Windows, Linux, Mac...
...wenn du das für die Uni machst...
...kannst du tatsächlich vielleicht sogar Linux sein...
...ich habe eigentlich keine Informatik studiert...
...aber ich arbeite noch...
...4 Tage die Woche...
...Windows...
...ja also unter Windows...
...mit dem normalen .NET Framework machen...
...oder mit .NET Core...
... .NET Core ist nochmal ne ganze Ecke was Performance angeht...
...schneller...
... .NET Core ist quasi so das neue .NET Framework...
...Microsoft möchte ja auch kein...
...nicht mehr das alte länger unterstützen...
...mit der nächsten Version...
...aber also...
...an sich finde ich...
...die Idee gar nicht mal so übel...
...wenn du sagst hey Java geht eh auf den Sack...
...könntest dir angucken sowas...
...mit C-Sharp...
...beziehungsweise dann unter Windows...
...wenn es eh Windows Only ist...
...mit DirectX zu machen...
...weil in der Regel...
...sind halt die...
...OpenGL Implementierung meilenweit...
...hinter der DirectX Geschichte unter Windows...
...ich meine man sieht es an Doom...
...und anderen Games ja...
...dass das mit OpenGL auch wunderbar funktioniert...
...wie schnell kannst du tippen...
...nicht so schnell...
...vor allem auf der Tastatur hier...
...mach ich übelst viele Tippfehler...
...ich habe das Gefühl...
...die Corsar Tastatur hat irgendwie...
...ein bisschen kleinere...
...ein halber Millimeter...
...total oft beim Tippen...
...tippe ich auf zwei Tasten anstatt auf eine...
...guck...
...schau wieder...
...auf der Tastatur ist es ganz schlimm...
...auf der anderen...
...auf dieser Ducky One Skyline...
...tippt es sich viel angenehmer...
...dafür ist die Corsar für Spiele...
...hier schöner...
...deswegen bleibe ich auch bei der...
...also wenn du C-Sharp Tutorials willst...
...wenn du auf...
...Buchform stehst...
...hallo...
...ich möchte gerne den Browser öffnen...
...wir machen jetzt...
...hier mal...
...ja...
...was ganz...
...gut ist...
...wenn du auf was in Buchform stehst...
...ist hier ist die...
...ach bin ich immer noch auf der indischen Tastatur...
...ich bin immer noch auf der indischen Tastatur...
...Microsoft denkt irgendwie...
...ich möchte eine indische Tastatur haben...
...das kannst du dir angucken...
...wenn du auf die Sache in Buchform stehst...
...das ist seit 2012...
...aber ganz ehrlich...
...das hat sich nicht viel geändert an den Grundlagen...
...das ist ein komplettes C-Sharp Buch von A bis Z...
...sagen wir mal so...
...die Hälfte davon kannst du weglassen...
...für deinen Zweck...
...wenn man das in Buchform mag...
...dann ist das hier echt gut...
...oder halt irgendwelche YouTube Videos...
...was ist denn ein Hardware Radtool...
...empfiehlt das einem Hardware...
...das ist ein YouTube Kollege...
...beziehungsweise...
...ein Hardware Shop...
...für die ich was gebastelt habe...
...ja ja kannst du machen Richie...
...kannst einfach fragen...
...so Leute es ist jetzt 22.25 Uhr...
...ich glaube...
...ich gehe jetzt pennen...
...also Leute...
...ich habe jetzt kompletten Dezember Urlaub...
...das heißt wir sehen uns jetzt wieder regelmäßig...
...und...
...vielleicht morgen schon...
...gucken wir mal...
...was ist denn...